there's no time o clock alright it's
Friday night
episode 192 UK crimes Johnny's got
something good for us tonight
that's right recover three cases all of
which have been requested at various
times some of them have been requested
several times going back like a year or
two ago and I'm just now getting around
to them I just decided to put them all
on one show cuz you know it's like I
have so many requested topics and like I
said I've just got to the point where
I'm just taking ones it's like these all
happen in the same country okay I'm
talking about get a book oh yeah reply
and I had to move kind of fast because I
know I know Jenny is she'll chill pick
like three or two or three subjects and
then she tries to carve them so
meticulously that's like a six hour show
seven hours show I'm trying not to do
that but it's like I I don't know it's
like at this really paranoid thing where
it's like I don't want this show to go
on forever because it's like a lot more
work for me to edit but then again I
don't want to like leave [ __ ] out and
then have people in and that had people
like wrong damn where you left this fact
out or you left that effect it's like
you don't have people's favourite facts
that's what I mean it and it's like so
it's really it kind of stresses me out
you guys because you know what I mean is
as I do do a lot of research for these
shows but you know I can't devote like
you know full time to it cuz I have like
write book I got I got a couple other
gigs going on daily shows yes so people
are that people on sidetrack sirs our
daily show there can become quite
popular we're getting regulars over
there you know they're asking us to
drink on the determine that and man I
felt like an alkene man we just filmed
those we usually film this in the early
after I guess yes I guess some of our
old-timers you know
with us from the very beginning because
they saw the main shows and we were
mostly doing them on the weekends they
just assume that I'm a [ __ ] last year
that you're a [ __ ] lush and then we
just drink 24/7 or drinking every
[ __ ] day
well yeah I love my we don't drink every
day you know and most days we do but
like well most evening is night before
we go to bed might have injure sometimes
have one or two that's normal what every
night we're drop watching movies and I
don't usually make them all that strong
sometimes I will yeah well on a weekend
night we do yeah and if we don't have to
record anything we don't think it up
early that exporting but yeah you know
in my family that was just kind of
normal to have a drink for you have a
drink before you bedded down yeah see I
always thought that was kind of like
even though like no one really drank in
my family like my parents didn't drink
or anything they weren't like you know
you can't drink or anything they just
wasn't a thing that they did but um it
definitely does seem like not that weird
it just does seem like a lot of people
come home from work and have like for
some diner can force cocktail or watch a
movie and that's it yeah it's like we're
not out running around rampage at the
drunken rampage
but yeah so talking about drinking it
might not seem very germane but it was
considered that drinking its well yeah
that's me drinking is like when I got a
I'm sitting there and I'm drinking one
after the other I'm at the club and
[ __ ] I come out hammered yeah that's
drinking that's different that's a lot
different yeah we don't usually get it
I'll do that he's like nah no I can
drunk at home yeah not home now like I
said I usually just have one like roll
we're watching a movie sometimes I'll
have a second one if there's one right
poor [ __ ] dog yeah it's like this
[ __ ] you want it's a double or a triple
okay that's just like that's just like
people that are on a diet they're just
like well I'm just gonna have one
cupcake and it's like I have one piece
of that pizza cuz I mean well pizza it's
like a quarter that's like a quarter
more that is one piece probably so so
good though
but yeah so uh like I said the the talk
of drinking might not seem like it's
very apropos but it actually is to the
first case that we're going to talk
about which we'll get into in a
bitte but before you do that let's do a
couple of shout outs cuz we got several
this week crap channels growing yes it
is got two new patrons Heather and Karen
well welcome on this show and thank you
a patron thank you very much and the
more patrons we have the [ __ ] more
show you have and the more we will be
here for you
the longer we will be here for you in
fact we're opening up a new payment plan
on YouTube Jenny's figuring that out now
but you could you can you can go through
YouTube if you don't want to do a
patreon yeah we're gonna do it we'll
probably do the tiers similar to what we
have going on on patreon
we'll probably either have two or three
tiers you know they can a $2 a $3 and a
$20 or a $2 $5 $20 fine like I said it's
similar to what we'll have on patreon so
get a lot of $20 patrons on we do on
patreon so we got to have a $20 one well
and I thought what I could do you know
if I do a YouTube membership is I'll do
the same thing that I do for patreon
people where you know the lower tiers
get you know you get like early access
to the shows and [ __ ] like that and then
20 and up you get shirt yeah see some
shirts I'm behind one on Rob yeah well
and I want to say that too because I
just like just before we started
recording this I got a PayPal a very
large PayPal donation from Jason who
sent us some before and using imagery
yeah and he was making a joke about
house it's like when do I get a shirt
when do I get a shirt I'm like we will
we're just like behind on making
everybody's because we haven't been able
to get out like all the [ __ ] craft
stores or clothes we have to make a new
shipment a lot of the places that like
jiffy shirts and stuff like that they're
operating it like severely like
understaffed yeah thing and it's like
they're really behind like on all their
[ __ ] so we don't even have a lot of
stuff to print the shirts we need to
come up with a couple of really badass
designs to I mean our designs are
getting better I like all the decides
that we have but I know we can get
better than that I know you can come up
with goals yet yeah we just got to hit
on the right thing I wanted to do 13
o'clock but I also want to be what they
call like a mishmash
yeah but I'm looking for a certain as
medic yeah you know it's all about yeah
I think you know I'm talking about
something that we wear to the club yeah
that's how I wanted to look yeah you can
come up with something
ya know I always come up I know you
always go I know but yeah so oh and also
uh somebody that we had that was already
a very generous patron increased their
support also a couple of days ago that
was Justin so thank you very much Justin
and again thank you Jason for your very
generous PayPal donation and I swear to
god we're gonna do the shirts we'll get
to him well guess there's a supply
chains open yeah it's like we've just
had a lot of trouble like getting you
know cuz we still need to get like
frames and ink and all that other kind
of [ __ ] couple couple stuff well it's
like hard to get yeah I just need that I
need two frames would be good and - yeah
things but I have everything else cuz
[ __ ] man even a lot of stuff we've it's
really weird because I've ordered some
stuff on Amazon that was not like
essential like I ordered some new memory
for my computer I ordered like some
makeup and hair dye and like just a
little like you know beauty product type
of stuff and that's just really behind
but then I got my shipment of shower gel
maybe shower gel is essential and makeup
isn't I'm not really sure but yeah but
then the weird thing was you ordered a
lighting thing yeah DMX yeah I got it we
got new we're gonna have a new show I
got a DMX and some pretty color in for
ya RGB I think they think all RGB lights
RGB RGB lights red green blue yes so
I'll be able to we're gonna have some
giallo lighting back there and I'll
totally it'll helping our games gonna
look good figured out but yeah but it's
oh we got the we got the chords for that
today yeah and you just ordered that
like a couple of days ago so do you
mention that showed up yeah I got the
DMX cables a DMX and the light so beer
tomorrow so we should be here more yeah
we'll sit so when I light it up we'll
have to futz around with that this
weekend and yeah see how it comes out
lots of cool colors maybe like some bug
in blue and some gold and we're [ __ ]
mood lighting up yes yeah that's right
alright so I think that's probably all
the shoutouts I mentioned the YouTube
membership thing like I said I don't
know how long it's gonna take for that
to go online
because they're understaffed and
everything but what's finished has just
got to go online um no we still have to
do like we have to record okay the video
I'd been a little bit [ __ ] like that
yeah but other than that I got most of
the other [ __ ] sort now all right so on
this show we are going to talk about
three cases UK crimes all crimes that
happened in England Wales or Scotland
although mostly England Scotland and
these have all been requested by various
people over the years sometimes more
than once we're gonna be covering the
pusher the purported serial killer
that's going around Manchester pushing
people into canals and killing them
we're also gonna talk about the tragic
murder of Sophie Lancaster very you know
which is very actually very well known
and they kind of goth obscene because
that's presumably why she was killed
yeah yeah I remember that case yeah it's
needed to [ __ ] a stop it those dudes
I get to death yeah yeah I remember when
that [ __ ] went down it was yeah I was
[ __ ] miss Evan I was [ __ ] mystified
I was [ __ ] miss as well I think a lot
of people were a lot of people were over
there too cuz everybody had a [ __ ]
forget about it it's like it was hugely
famous case and the third case we're
gonna talk about is the very famous
World's End murder in Edinburgh Scotland
which happened in 1977 but then it
turned out that the guy that did it who
didn't get caught until much later on
actually turned out to be a serial
rapists and serial killer named Angus
Sinclair and you know after they found
out that he was responsible for those
two but then they found out that he was
responsible oh watch other [ __ ] too he's
dead now he just recently he died last
year but we're gonna get into that as
well so let's start by talking about the
Manchester pusher case yeah now I
mentioned on one of our side tracks
probably Friday's that I've been reading
about cuz remember we did the show about
the smiley face theory yeah this is yeah
if you haven't seen that show there's a
similar kind of circumstance yes we
think I think a similar type of thing
is going on but it's kind of a it's kind
of like an analogous situation in the
sense that somebody somewhere has
noticed that a whole [ __ ] ton of people
usually college aged males are turning
up dead in the canals of Manchester
England and although many of these
deaths are accidental or ruled
accidental some people tend to think
that a lot of them are murders and that
there is somebody there's either a
serial killer or a gang of serial
killers that is going around and that's
their modus operandi is pushing people
into the canal to kill them much like in
the smileyface murders case which happen
to the United States which you know to
me is even less likely because it
happened and like a whole bunch of
different states like usually in the
Midwest and there's there was some other
ones in New England and [ __ ] too I think
yeah and each each individual
circumstance would have been kind of
like a very petty murder with that no
motive behind it with a big distance
between them all which would require a
lot of organization well it's a lot of
money and what is speculation about this
smileyface
theory is that and this is kind of ties
in with the with the pusher thing too is
that some people think that on the you
know fabled dark web it's not fable that
does actually exist but on the dark web
that there's a loose group of fuck-ups
and horrible people who that's kind of
like their thing and so they'll so they
they like are not organized really but
they're just like a dark web group and
it's like they just kind of go push
people into canals for shits and giggles
and whatever city that they're in and
I'm highly skeptical obviously but
unlikely variants I'm saying that done
lightly and any be it's very unlikely
for something like that to go undetected
for this amount of time somebody would
have said something by now and as I said
and I think I and I think I probably
mentioned this on the smiley face killer
show and this is kind of where I'm going
with the Manchester pusher case as well
I'm not saying that every single case
this is an accident I'm not saying that
it's completely possible that one or
several of them were murders or suicides
or something like that I'm just saying
that do I think that there is a person
or persons who is going around and
that's how they're killing people
pushing them into canals or pushing them
into the water so I just don't think
that's the case it doesn't seem like a
very effective way of killing someone no
but I mean there's there's a lot of
evidence I mean there are a couple of
cases and a couple of medic I'm gonna
talk about I can't like talk about all
of them because there were like a really
lot but some of the cases I'm gonna talk
about there were some like weird
circumstances surrounding it where maybe
there was something else going on but by
and large I think the vast majority of
these are probably accidental deaths
it's some kind of statistical phenomenon
that's what I believe yeah based on what
you told me we discussed this a little
bit before the show earlier this morning
when I got off of seven coffee I was
sitting over there and she was telling
me about the case and I was like oh yeah
and that's this that it's easy for
statistics to kind of play on your mind
it's kind of like fuzzy math you know
you know what I mean like you can you
can connect dots that aren't there
yeah I'm connecting between dots that
aren't there you know it's just
mathematical probabilities yeah and so
got water there's a mathematical
probability that people are gonna
drowned in it people yes you will see in
the particular case of the Manchester
pusher not only does Manchester have
about 10 miles of canals but a lot of
the canals are one have stretches where
they are unprotected I they do not have
railings or anything on the side of them
two are right next to like big city
centers where there are guess what pubs
yeah so you know and like where there's
like a lot of people particularly on
weekend nights and stuff like that so
let's kind of get into this now even
though there were some cases beforehand
and even you know before this happened
there were still like rumors going
around man
that maybe there was somebody going
around pushing people into canals for
shits and giggles like to kill people
that way
but I think kind of it went global or
viral or whatever you want to call it in
early 2015 now this was when a newspaper
The Daily Star Sunday they had polled
they had they did a Freedom of
Information Act thing because there had
been all these rumors swirling about all
these people dying in the Manchester
canals so they did a Freedom of
Information request and found out that
in six years the prior six years so to
2015 so presumably back to 2009 that 61
bodies had been pulled out of the
Manchester waterways now it should be
noted that actually the body the the
body count was actually higher it was
actually I believe 85 bodies although
that included Greater Manchester which
also includes like all the suburbs and
everything like that the 61 figure was
you know the city centre Manchester
proper rather than like all like
Rochdale and all the kind of outer lying
boroughs or whatever so so the newspaper
like goes to the Greater Manchester
Police and is like you know look 61
bodies in six years that seems like a
lot have you guys like looked into this
and everything now the police are saying
look there's no link there these are
generally seen as like accidental deaths
or whatever now along comes this guy who
he was a professor at Birmingham
University his name was Craig Jackson
now let me note right off the bat that
as far as I am aware Craig Jackson is
not a statistician I believe he is a
psychologist or psychiatrist that's what
his area of expertise but it was cut he
was kind of thinking look all these
bodies you know coming out of that
that's unusual
so he was the one that kind of
kick-started the whole idea that maybe
this was a serial killer like ice or
maybe kind of codified it because it
does seem like there were kind of rumors
swirling before that well let me ask you
this okay is there a clear date
this phenomena began see it's not really
because I do feel like you know yes the
newspaper that came out in 2015 and they
said okay since 2009 sixty-one bodies
have been pulled out of the canal but
the thing about it is that if you look
at other like older newspapers and [ __ ]
like that there were bodies being pulled
out of the canal prior to that although
but it doesn't really seem like anybody
you know they're not like they weren't
like paying a lot of attention to it
until and I don't know necessarily
because it's kind of hard to get
information about all this you know it's
very just scattershot but it it's kind
of hard to tell whether there were more
or less or less yeah that's because how
much you bet the population was smaller
maybe yeah maybe more [ __ ] like that and
have lived in that particular I bet you
if you had a clear a clear body of
information how much bill fell in that
fell in over the years you find out
there was no beginning point they were
always falling in and drowning it was
just fewer and fewer of them as you
moved backwards in time yeah as the
population was smaller it's probably
population dependent which means
statistical I kind of feel like that's I
mean mostly statistic Euler alert I
think this is probably mostly a
statistic not to say that they were all
by accident yeah I love them probably
could have been murders yeah because
there are and I'll get into it and there
have been a couple of cases that they
know were somebody that got pushed in
and like they lived and got pushed in
like they were getting mugged or
whatever so it does happen yeah but I
just don't think all of them were that
it's just we have a similar phenomenon
here in Florida some of these some of
these neighborhoods have like these
canals that run in between them down the
south those alligators in them yeah and
there's just a constant amount of dogs
being eaten by the alligators you're not
people aren't drowning in there because
it's not deep enough yeah but it's water
and there's alligators in it this is a
similar kind of situation its water and
as deep and drunks are falling in it
yeah a certain amount of them are gonna
[ __ ] die another thing about the
canals in Manchester too is that for
most of the year they're really cold ah
yeah kick in [ __ ] crazy especially if
you're drunk
yep you can't get out in time and yeah
and I'll go into that a little bit
because I should I'm just gonna
recommend this right here I'll get into
it a little bit later on and now the
better the data skews towards deaths in
the winter it may I'm not entirely sure
but there's like a really good two-part
documentary it's about it's almost two
hours long on this channel called
curiosity and this guy I think is Gary
something I can't remember but he did
like a really in-depth look at the
Manchester pusher theory and um he he
did some crazy [ __ ] like it it's a good
documentary though he really liked when
it today I think that he kind of came
down he was he was actually very
even-handed in it he didn't come down on
either side he didn't say yeah I think
it's a serial killer yeah I think it's
all accidents but he just like presented
all of the information and he got like
interviews with like a lot of like the
victim's parents and stuff like that so
like I said so here's this guy professor
Craig Jackson and he kind of came out of
like bolstering the serial killer theory
because he's like that many bodies you
know turning up in a body order that
short amount of time is unusual so the
police should be looking into a theory
that they're all lengthened that this is
linked in this is one person or a series
of people doing this so between 2008 and
2014 there were 85 people that died in
rivers canals or other waterways in
Greater Manchester like I said and that
is a that is a much much larger area
that's like hundreds of square miles as
opposed to just like the city centre 72
of these victims were men just like in
the smiley face thing here in the United
States almost all of the victims are men
so most of these cases now the police
investigated all of these cases
obviously because some of these men were
ones that like went missing and then
their bodies weren't found until much
later on because you know when you fall
in the water your body kind of tends to
move like with the current
and sometimes it's not found where it
went in and what hot
most of these were ruled accidents
however there were I believe 28 cases
that came back with open verdicts and
that they couldn't definitively say it
was an accident they couldn't
definitively say that something else
might not have happened so these are the
cases that a lot of people are kind of
focusing on because these are the ones
where they couldn't come down
definitively and say that they were
accidents even though some people that
are more like conspiracy theory minded
think that oh the police are covering up
and like all the other ones aren't
accidents either but I don't really buy
that I can see how there's like some
some you know people being curious about
these 28 particular cases because they
couldn't you know come down and say yes
we definitely know this was an accident
because there were maybe other weird
mitigating circumstances but the other
ones I'm pretty sure they just kind of
dismissed him because they were just
already accidents now what I should say
so I'm gonna go into a couple of the
cases and a couple of these to me seem
like accidents although a couple of them
do have some unusual details that maybe
suggest something else was going on so
one of these guys one of the victims was
named David Plunkett he was 21 years old
now he was actually found dead in
Manchester Ship Canal in 2012
now the creepiest thing about him he had
been at a party or he had been like at a
like a music thing I think it was like
for Budweiser it was like some kind of
Budweiser promotional event they had
bands and [ __ ] like that
so it was in Trafford Park and he um he
apparently had phoned his parents or had
texted his parents and said like he
wasn't really that drunk or he was on
his way home because he was like you
know he'd been out all day or whatever
now what happened was that the phone
rang at his parents house and his
parents picked it up and it was his
number but they didn't hear anything
it was just silence so his mom keeps
trying to like trying to get him to talk
trying to get in to talk
but she doesn't hear anything then all
of a sudden like she's on the phone for
like it's elegant a long time like an
hour or something like that she said so
she's trying to show like David David
like what are you doing what's the
matter like where are you are you lost
or something like that I guess she
thought he went out and got drunk and
like didn't know where he was or
something but she couldn't really hear
him talking she said she could hear
somebody breathing maybe or like you
know but she couldn't really hear
anything else she's like it wasn't like
loud it wasn't like he was at you know
the music venue or anything like that it
was just like he was out walking around
on the street she said then all of a
sudden she heard what she's sure is her
son howling and screaming okay like back
now I should note that they didn't hear
anyone else's voice and she didn't hear
water splashing however he was found
dead in the canal he fell in the damn
water so yes so I'm kind of wondering
like didn't he just fall in or did
someone mug him and he fell in or look
something now where he fell in at her
where he went in the water
is it a sheer drop into the water or is
it got like a bank that's not sure
because like from what it because like I
said the Manchester canal system is huge
and it's like it has different things in
different places like some parts of it
you know the canal is just like right
there it's very much like Amsterdam
where it's just like you know houses or
bars sidewalk and then
okay drop off well look if you jump in
the water and you hit feet first and
you're kind of like this you don't make
much noise that's true so you know it's
conceivable she wouldn't hear him fall
on him but she did hear him [ __ ]
scream for help maybe especially and
this is this was it called uh this was
actually I believe it was in yeah it was
in spring okay so it wasn't what I think
it was in April but um so that's so
faith so they are speculating that maybe
Swift currents do we know not
necessarily there is a current but not
you know it's just a canal there's like
there's boat locks right and you know if
he was a strong swimmer or a weak so
ever see a lot of these I don't know see
you know that's [ __ ] that's
important yeah you know if you're in a
current you have a good person who's a
non swimmer
that's still a deadly situation yeah you
know I'm a strong swimmer and I've been
in Swift currents and just bucket you're
getting pulled out you know you can't
fight that well yeah that's happened to
me on the ocean before you get caught in
a rip current that or Riptide out in the
ocean yeah yeah I got pulled out yeah
when I swung my straw on back you don't
go out that far well what they tell you
to do quit it you just kind of either
swim with or swim to you know till one
side it's going in a big kind of like
circles seemed like yeah and it
eventually stopped then I just went back
I was a little kid though bad yeah I was
scared well it's scary
Harry when it happens because you're
just swimming and it's like normal and
then all of a sudden you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah I was lucky that was tough swim
[ __ ] it I mean remember when I learned
to swim this I don't either
well you know I grew up in Florida it's
like row surrounded by water
yeah round yeah your parents really you
know better make sure really I I would
not advise living in Florida not know I
had this one I just don't advise it
period well yeah I'm just saying
actually in Florida yes like but you
know not only is this place surrounded
by water there's [ __ ] lakes
everywhere but a lot of people have
pools yeah so you know so I can see why
um in this particular case they thought
maybe something happened to him prior to
him falling in and that it wasn't an
accident like I can understand that I
think it probably was an accent the
police did say that his body did not
have any evidence that he had been
assaulted or you know anything like that
that would suggest that someone else had
thrown him into the water or somebody
else had beaten him up or somebody had
done something of that nature so there
was another guy named Nathan Tomlinson
and he was also 21 now he had been out
at a work Christmas party so this was
winter and he disappeared I guess it was
in like early December I don't think it
was like right on Christmas but they
didn't find him for like two months now
this was in the river or well now they
thought his death death was suspicious
at least his parents did because his
kote his phone his passport and his
wallet were never found
hmm so I'm not sure if he was robbed or
if he just fell in and the stuff just
fell out of his pockets and then they
just never found it because it's in the
water and it just like got swept away or
whatever like he still has clothes on
and [ __ ] but all of his [ __ ] was gone
and they never did find it so some
people have speculated that maybe that
was a robbery gone wrong or something at
that so you can see like why the serial
killer theory has kind of taken hold
because a couple of these cases do have
little details like that that could
suggest that something bad happened is
I'm not saying that it's a serial killer
and that's their mo is pushing people in
the water I'm just saying that maybe
they got mugged and the canal was right
there and like the guy took their [ __ ]
and they got just like fill it or push
it or whatever one of the reasons why
I'm gonna go against a serial killer
drowning people [ __ ] theory serial
killers don't have that as a motive
serial killers are rapists there's
serial rapists they don't want to push
somebody in the damn water they can't
rape them you know and I mean that's
that's debt that's the typical serial
killer so I'm gonna say it's probably
not what's going on it just seems like a
very odd because here's the thing that's
not to say that some of these aren't
crimes oh yeah I'm sure something was
there just because their crimes doesn't
mean they're connected yeah that's
exactly that's exactly right and that's
it and I don't want people to think that
it's like I think that every single one
of these are accidents I don't know
I do think because there have been a
couple of documented cases over there
where somebody you know like a gang of
people like set upon somebody and mugged
them and then either push them in or
they fell in or whatever during the
course of the mugging I think I believe
that was one crime to where the mugger
actually fell in like during the attack
so it does happen cuz like I said there
are large stretches of this these canals
in Manchester where there is no railing
the lighting is bad you know I mean
there's there's huge like [ __ ] you
know miles and miles of these things so
in a lot of the places yes that you know
there's [ __ ] you know signs and
railings and [ __ ] there
but some places there's not and some
places there's you know several feet of
drop down it's not deep on the side in
the middle it is but it's only about
three feet deep on the side so I believe
most of it you can stand up if you just
go and like right by the right by the
water but the water is very cold too
and some of the places are not well lit
you know and if you're completely pissed
out of your skull then that's gonna make
life more difficult for you but so you
know so I'm saying I'm not saying that
like all of these are accidents I'm sure
that some of them happened in the course
of another crime I just don't know which
ones are which and most of the bodies
that they found did not have any
evidence on them that the person had
been assaulted well I'm gonna tell you
right now just based on statistics and
everything that I've learned the ones
that were crimes okay probably we're not
connected and there's no way that was a
serial killer yes
see I don't gotta say either serial
killers are serial rapists that kill the
victim this is not gonna provide the
serial killer what he's looking for
yeah cuz he's getting rid of the person
yeah he can't get to it because it
where's the sexual experience unless
they get off on just like watching
people drown which some people do but
you know I don't know I'm just kind of
there was a whole dark web thing to get
that guy that I watched the documentary
on he found like all these dark websites
where like people got ugly out of fetish
about drowning yeah they're watching it
and they're beating off yeah he said the
weird thing about it though he's like I
couldn't find any porn that was like of
men drowning it was all look like women
were willing to drown yeah okay cuz it's
dudes watching it I don't yeah I don't
think this is straight serial killer I
think it's I think it's all um
unconnected cases me as some of them
crimes that's just this is just yeah
because you I learned my mama
I mean Manchester is a massive city it's
one of the largest cities in England and
you know they it's not like you know an
American city in terms of crime but it
does have
a lot of crime and the places around the
canals you know a lot of it is like
really dark a lot of us around pubs
you're getting a lot of drunk guys run
around on the street in the dark getting
in fights you know [ __ ] like that yes
some dude you throw his ass in them yes
so there's repo preying on you know and
there's a large you know gay community
there like there's a lot of gay bars
like on Canal Street and stuff like that
and for a time the LBGT LGBTQ community
was worried that somebody was like
targeting gay men and stuff like that
because a few of the victims were but
you know and I'm not saying that that
wasn't the case too I'm sure so but I
don't think it's the same person doing
all of it I just think that because
there are so many people in this one
area because so many people are drinking
because there's a lot of areas where you
can like not be seen it's a good place
to commit a crime if you're so inclined
to do that some of them are gonna be
stuff like two dudes [ __ ] [ __ ] up
blasted fighting each other [ __ ] one
dude throws the other one in the water
he can't swim and then he can't get
around and he's like oh [ __ ] yeah and he
doesn't want to tell anybody
yeah I guess I could totally see that
happening no looking at some of the
photographs of where the where these
canals are where the bars are enjoy show
them and stuff I could totally see that
I'm in fact I'm surprised it doesn't
happen more often [ __ ] out
there fight and drunk as [ __ ] [ __ ]
one do to knock some [ __ ]
knocks him out
Wow and then they [ __ ] throws us ass
in the drink and then dude realize this
oh [ __ ] he was unconscious
yeah and they drowns yeah I mean that's
what I mean I could totally see that oh
that he's gonna be [ __ ] like that yeah a
lot of it I don't even I don't think
it's planned in the sense that yeah it's
somebody that's saying I'm gonna push
[ __ ] in the water and kill them
that way I just think it ends up
happening because the canal is there
yeah and people are drunk and it's like
and they can't get out or whatever
happens yeah some of its fight yeah so
um another creepy thing in the Nathan
Tomlinson case was there was actually
CCTV footage some footage of him while
he was still alive and he had texted his
parents
quite early I think it was only like
10:30 or something like I said he'd been
to work Christmas party like at a pub
and he text him quite early said I'm
just drinking shandies and you know I'll
probably be home soon I guess he wasn't
really feeling it because you know work
Christmas party and in case you don't I
didn't know if you know know what a
Shandy is no I don't know Andy it's a
it's I believe it's half beer half
lemonade it's like a cut it's like beer
cup of lemonade damn that's terrible um
they're actually pretty good I know them
over there but that's kind of what you
drink when you don't want to get too
[ __ ] up you know what I mean
yeah so he was just drinking I'll try it
try one we got something kind of like
that here in the United States I thought
I learned how to make it in Boston it's
called snake bite yeah those are really
good actually yeah snake bite and snake
bite is like half and half that doesn't
the UK - I'm in the UK okay it's like we
call it [ __ ] looking real dark lager
whereas with Guinness it's like Guinness
Extra Stout with cider it's kind of so
that's kind of like a shot this entire
half yeah there was something else -
there's another thing that these
diseased to take damn cider used to take
cider and took a shot glass of something
and drop it down in there and go to the
bottom punk and they wouldn't but I
forgot what that was called I can't
remember and there was that might have
been Jagermeister in that [ __ ] shot
it was I think it was I remember cuz I
used to work for van Gogh vodka yeah and
I remember doing I remember they had
like a big [ __ ] campaign for doing
[ __ ] in my 20s that coming out of the
arm out blasted like crazy at The
Rathskeller
oh it's gone now yeah you got you old
school punk rockers nobody yeah Sex
Pistols played there's one the other
places in the United States I think sex
doesn't play there yeah because they
they weren't here very long I've been
remodeled yeah I've been thinking about
the Ramones I think it was there was
yeah yeah I don't think they made it to
there it was it was one of the old punk
rock bands I think was the Ramones
yeah but they had some CCTV footage of
someone that the police thought was
Nathan and they thought it was strange
because even though Nathan had texted
his family that he was coming home the
person on the CCTV camera pierced
be walking in the opposite direction to
where Nathan lives and he was walking
this reared Li circuitous route and he
was actually running and like looking
behind him as though someone was chasing
him although no they couldn't see anyone
behind him so the police thought that
was a little weird but like I said you
know on the body they couldn't really
find anything and it should be noted
that his mom watching that CCTV footage
and I've seen it and I don't know how
they could [ __ ] tell who the hell
that is because it just looks like a
little white blur his mom does not think
that that is him the police seem to
think it's him I'm not really sure why
they don't know why he was where he was
or why he was running or whatever but
it's like I don't know if that had
anything to do with anybody seeing him
or anything like that so there was
another guy named Chris brawny who was
22 now he had been in a Stone Roses
concert in 2012 he was also his body was
also found in the Manchester Ship Canal
ten days after he went missing now they
also caught him partially on CCTV
cameras he they said he came on a tram
from Victoria Station and he went and
got like a bag and then he was like he
was going through the city centre and
then he went onto a Riverside walkway
and then the camera couldn't see him
anymore so they're presuming that he
must have either been thrown or fallen
into the water shortly afterward because
he went missing shortly after that but
they didn't really notice anything that
unusual about what you know like what he
was doing you know what I mean
so then there was another guy named
Subic pal and he was 18 and he was a
student at Manchester Metropolitan
University now this was uh this happened
New Year's Eve 2012 now he had been
kicked out of a bar at the warehouse
project I heard that it was either
because he was on ecstasy or because I
guess it could be and or and or because
he was trying to but in line for the
bathrooms because I guess he really had
to go y'all and when you really have to
go you really have to go but yeah so
I've heard both things I don't know if
it was cuz he was on drugs or because he
was trying to get in front of everybody
or
the things I don't know but he got
thrown out and then he went missing and
22 days later they found his body in the
Bridgewater canal now he did have drugs
in his system although they're assuming
that that wasn't mckitten because there
has been some speculation that maybe
some of these people are getting drugged
because I'll get into a little bit later
but there was a serial rapist operating
in Manchester around this time period
who did drug men with GHB and then raped
them he didn't kill them though as far
as they know but it was a lot of people
so so it wasn't unheard of I was a butt
pirate yeah big time but um trying to
steal the booty no this particular guy
even though they did find drugs in his
system
this guy was another guy that they
caught on CCTV and it appeared that he
was walking with someone who they didn't
recognize or someone was following him
and they're not entirely sure who it is
now this guy's dad actually came there
from India he he was just over here the
son was just over here in college so I
believe the dad either moved to England
or either came over like for the in
question the investigation or whatever
and he is convinced that his son was
killed by someone and that it wasn't an
accident
so he's kind of out there like
campaigning and [ __ ] like that so you
know I should say that I don't think
it's that crazy that people are thinking
that somebody is go around deliberately
pushing people into the canals because
there was a case where that demonstrably
did happen I think it does happen yeah
and they and I mean they caught the
people involved is what I'm saying I
just don't think it's all connected
because yeah yeah that's what I'm sorry
that's why
yeah that's I'm not saying that I think
that these people are doing it but I'm
just saying that that's why I can
understand why people think they think
that it's happening because it does
happen I just don't think it's the same
I don't think it's I think like it's
yeah it's not like a connected thing
yeah so 2013 there were four men and a
kid who was 15 I believe
had been going on a robbery spree around
the Rochdale canal which is in the city
center now they actually did push one
guy named Simon brass who was 40 years
old
into the canal and left him there to die
I don't believe he did actually die but
they pushed him in there and we're like
robbing him and stuff so they actually
admitted it after after they were caught
I guess he did die because they got they
got robbery and I guess they had
manslaughter so I guess that guy did die
but so that did happen in 2013 it was a
gang and they were robbers and they
pushed him into the canal and he died
and earlier in the same night that the
that Simon brass died they had also
pushed another guy into the water and
when he tried to get out one of the gang
like stepped on his fingers like they
were trying to keep him from coming out
now in 2018 there was another case like
that there was another guy and he just
he didn't want his name known so into
the in the media he's just called Tom
and he was a cycling home along a lot
along a toe path like along the canal
like late at night he was coming home
from work or something and he said all
of a sudden like this guy just jumped
out from the bushes and just like
whacked him like off his bike and then
he knocked him into Bridgewater canal
which is like really really cold water
so he the guy like Tom starts trying to
crawl out of the canal and the guy like
starts trying to kick him back in there
so at this point I mean this was 2018 so
the guy knew like Tom knew he's like oh
[ __ ] this must be the pusher though like
that's if it's all true you know what I
mean so the this part of the towpath and
I'll get into this a little bit in a
minute because they talked about this on
the documentary but there aren't any
lights along it's just pretty much like
a dirt path and then there's like a
canal it's not that deep but and then
there's like all these little houseboats
like you know a bunch of people live in
houseboats like along this particular
canal so he just got like knocked in
like he got out and he lived but he did
say the guy deliberately pushed him in
there and then like deliberately tried
to get him from to come from coming out
hmm
so he did actually manage to get out he
reported it to the police but told the
media that he didn't think they
took it all that seriously so that's
kind of where that ended now I mentioned
before that there was a guy who was
operating around the manchester city
center that was a serial rapist that was
actually drugging guys on raping them
this was a guy named rain hard sing gaga
he was originally from Indonesia but he
was a student in Manchester and they
think that between 2015 and 2017 that he
raped at least a hundred and fifty nine
people damn he would generally pick them
up in bars and drugged them with GHB and
then he would rape them yeah he didn't
kill anybody though I don't think so
because of this has something on this
dude yeah it was a little harmless
looking [ __ ] yeah he's just like
a little fella yeah I remember that dude
yeah yeah so um he was making videos
about it he's talking to the video yeah
yeah we're going like what's that what's
happened yeah I talk rag about it yes
and he's making all these dudes gay
that's some weird [ __ ] man yeah yeah so
he just got convicted
I believe in early this year um like
January of 2020 and he got convicted of
159 sex offences I don't think it was
100 didn't like his effort victims I
think it was any lock his ass up
centered a prison but that's kind of
like the equivalent of locking me up in
some kind of girls school Tommy just be
good I just had a great you I had a
really funny like mental picture of Tom
just like run around naked you know
within the girls is cracked up thinking
about that but so because of this guy's
mo a lot of people have kind of like
been bugging the greater man chirp
manchester police saying like why don't
you look into this guy being the pusher
because clearly he's going around
drugging people and it wouldn't really
be that much crazier for him to just
like dump people
canal's or kill people or whatever but
as far as I know he's only been
convicted of like sexual assaults like
sexual crimes I don't know dude was not
violent he wasn't mean-spirited he well
I think what I was doing was mean well
yeah it's mean-spirited he thought he
was being cool though
I saw that dude yeah he thought was yes
go go the like drug people into
unconscious oh he thought it was [ __ ]
awesome oh this is his first gay
experience and the dudes [ __ ] knocked
out and [ __ ] yes even if he would have
enjoyed it as a roommate you think she's
[ __ ] bringing magic to these dudes
these dudes a [ __ ] [ __ ] down [ __ ]
that's ludicrous
yeah what a ludicrous person that guy is
but yeah so a lot of people have you
know thought that maybe this guy or like
I said this is another thing that's kind
of like pointing to people saying see
the pusher could be real because this
[ __ ] was running around and he's
real and it's not that crazy so because
there was so much kind of like brouhaha
about the pusher story the Greater
Manchester Police they said okay well
we're just gonna in 2016 they said we're
gonna do a review of all the cases like
all the open verdicts that have been
like you know that all the people that
have been pulled out of the canal that
that they weren't sure you know what
happened to them and after that review
they came to pretty much the same
conclusion that we have just come to
that there was no connection that there
is no serial killer you know that it's
just they're largely accidents every now
and then you get a crime and maybe there
is something going on there but in the
aggregate they're thinking that these
are probably accidents because you have
to think okay so here's the thing
there's other cities another thing that
kind of like makes me think that this is
obviously not a serial killer
it's because there are other cities in
England even that have like extensive
canal systems are a lot of waterways
such as bath or Bristol or even London
Yorkshire it's like they have similar
urban legends because they have similar
[ __ ] happenings like people drowning in
the canals and in fact I thought this
was kind of [ __ ] up but in your
sure their version of the Manchester
pusher is called the Yorkshire Dipper
because a Yorkshire Ripper I mean
there's that old English dark humour
yeah I love it
but yes like that's kind of [ __ ] up
but it's also pretty funny also you have
cities like Amsterdam which has a very
similar canal system to Manchester's and
they have a similar problem although
they seem to have more safety measures
in place one of the things that freaks
me out about Manchester and actually a
lot of people that live there too
because there's like a huge campaign
that went on particularly after the
death of one college student named
Charlie Pope who was 19 notably his dad
does think that his death was an
accident but that kind of caused him is
like hey can we please like have some
more safety measures around these
[ __ ] canals because look there's
whole stretches of it where there's
nothing dudes are coming out of the
[ __ ] pub just stank drunk I mean just
[ __ ] [ __ ] up they're gonna taking a
piss and the [ __ ] canal and falling
in maybe hitting their head on their way
down yeah and then they're [ __ ] hit
and hitting the drink unconscious you
gonna [ __ ] die I mean anybody could
die that way that's what I mean it's not
very easily can happen because you can
say well he knew how to swim but you
don't know what happened before he got
into the water he might have fallen on
his way down and hit ahead on that
little edge because maybe he went out
this way boom and hit ass first and then
[ __ ] went up his back and he hit the
base of his skull on the edge and hit
the water he was knocked out I've seen
it happen on the side of a swimming pool
yes sober people yeah and you can you
can [ __ ] be unconscious and inhale
one breath of water and that's all it
takes it kills you almost instantly yeah
yeah so I do feel like that there's and
and like I said there's a huge push in
Manchester to you know I didn't really
mean to say it like that but you know
there's like a huge campaign rather
that's a better way of putting it to put
more like safety like safety railings
better lighting [ __ ] like that like some
of the plaits some of it has railings
but there's really an alarmingly large
portion of it where cuz I'm look look
go and you have got to be [ __ ]
kidding me with that it's like it's like
I'd probably fall in that [ __ ] dead
sober cuz I'm just yeah what I think
statistically it's dudes pissing off the
[ __ ] side I think so too and and I
wanted to get into this a little bit too
because when I found with their [ __ ]
pants on well okay now let their fly's
open
well yeah that's what I was gonna say
about when they have had like
statisticians and things like that look
into this there they're like we want to
see like other cities like Amsterdam
that have like a large canal system
comparable to Manchester's we wanted to
see what their [ __ ] was now it should be
noted that the deaths in Greater
Manchester is comparable to Amsterdam's
death even though Amsterdam has more
canals than Manchester does but there
might be some other factors at play I
think Amsterdam has more safety measures
around their canal so it's harder to
fall in perhaps so from a statistical
point of view there are about fourteen
canal or river deaths in Greater
Manchester per year which to me it
sounds like a lot but then it kind of
doesn't you know what I mean 14 people a
year is not really that many considering
how many people live there I mean like I
said it's it's a very large city so
Amsterdam has 165 canals they have about
18 drownings a year now the vast
majority of these are young men and
somebody like a Dutch guy that looked
into all this he said that's not
specific to Amsterdam that's something
specific to men you see the same pattern
happening all over the world in cities
where you have canals and waterways
running in between like city centres
where people live or where there are
bars or whatever he said and this is a
quote in all kinds of accidents men are
always over-represented men are more
likely to be risk takers and more likely
to walk home alone at night
that goddamn testosterone it is yep it's
it's a poison I wish I had more of it
TRT
there you go they also pointed out that
most drownings happened on four
or Saturday nights obviously more than
half of them had been drinking heavily
or taking drugs that's what it is 10% of
the men's bodies have been found with
their zippers open there it is so
there's yes so that's what I mean so I
feel like whether this is fight it's
people just slipping and falling men
have a thing about peeing into the
bottom water they have a thing I don't
have no evidence behind I guess I'm a
girl so I don't really know I don't know
what it is or some other like even when
I was like researching this case like
every dude that was like yeah it's like
there's something really satisfying and
instinctive how you doing poop you look
at me cuz I'm talking yeah what are you
talking about yeah it's like what are
you talking you talking to me
can you talk it to me come here she's
that funny okay yeah there's something
instinctive about heading towards the
water and taking a piss in it yeah
you're not gonna do that if you're
drinking out of that same water it's
maybe there's some kind of masculine
instinct to [ __ ] contaminate somebody
else's water maybe what it is a water
[ __ ] [ __ ] your water alright it's right
that alright and then you move on it's
gotta be something that's inherited from
[ __ ] the animals yeah I thought about
because I think that happens a lot too
with cuz you know how sometimes like
dudes will go fishing like out on the
boat and then they disappear and [ __ ] I
think a lot of her peeing off the side
of the boat yeah and you know not to be
drunk for that to happen either because
I've fallen lots of times and I was
completely he always thought I was being
I always thought that yawning was a long
process
and I found out later was I was I heard
some of some about it on another show
that was added with forensics all you
have to do is inhale once a full a full
breath of water into your lungs and it
basically renders you unconscious
instantly actually we were talking about
that that dude that was murder and his
wives back in the 1800's by [ __ ]
lifting their feet up where they were in
the tub yeah and it only took one breath
and that scared the [ __ ] out he'll cuz
I'm like look how easy that is
yeah cuz I'm so fragile I can't sit up
because your heads underneath the water
that's holding their feet up and you you
try to do a sit-up but you're already in
the maximum sit-up position yeah so you
can't get your head out of the water you
can drown a person in a damn foot of
water yeah you don't get much water that
should I should say and I all I have to
do is take one breath underneath there
and they're in there rendered
unconscious way too much yeah yeah so
like I said I mean drowning I think it's
um
far as I can remember I don't know if
this is correct him but I'm pretty sure
this is correct I think it's the third
most common cause of accidental death in
the world if you fell in and you had a
strong response when would you that
might render you unconscious well that's
what I mean and and I want to get into
this in a second too but before here's
another thing like that's kind of like
against the whole serial killer theory
is that if there was somebody that was
deliberately going around pushing people
into canals to kill them let's say like
for the sake of argument um you would
think that there would be like people
that were too strong for the dude who
got out of the canal you know what I
mean and then later reported it and said
hey some [ __ ] crazy person tried to
push me to the canal and I crawled back
out but you you're not really seeing
that it's like there's a couple cases
like I said the case of the pseudonymous
Tom who was knocked into the canal and
then like you know the the guys like
tried to kick him back in there but as
far as I know that's pretty much one of
the only times that that's happened you
think if it was like a big if there was
a guy like going around like pushing 85
[ __ ] people in the water who all died
it's like that there'd be lots and lots
of survivors because not everybody is
gonna die when they go in the water
somebody is gonna kick that dudes ass is
what I'm saying especially when you're
picking on and this was something much
as I think I mentioned when we were
talking about smiley face murders it's
like there's a reason why serial killers
and stuff like that usually target women
and children because targeting 20-year
old men is not usually the best idea get
you ask because one of them is gonna
beat your ass
it's like especially serial killers who
tend to be kind of weedy little suckers
anyway
you know what I mean see Morgan you're
gonna get your [ __ ] ass handed to you
one of these days and I feel like that
doesn't happen yeah so I want to get
into a little bit like I said this this
guy who has a channel called curiosity
and he did like a two-hour documentary
it's in two parts it's on YouTube you
can watch it about the Manchester pusher
case one thing that he mentioned now
this is hilarious because in the at the
end of the first episode he was like I
am going to get piss blind drunk and
throw myself into the canal and see if I
can get out like he had like safety
measures like he had all these divers
hey guys wait with and with him that you
know he had like four divers set up
experience and he had him like go and
like sweep the bottom of the thing and
all this other kind of [ __ ] good
experiment but it turned out that like
when the second one he's like okay well
three of my divers like bowed out and
they didn't want to do it so I only have
one diver left
he's like which means that I probably
should not do this drunk because he was
talking to the divers and the diver was
even like on camera going on the record
I think this is a stupid idea to put a
rope on him no they should've done a
rope on him yeah but he's like not only
could you fall in the canal and you know
the canal waters really cold he's like
but it could be like there could be [ __ ]
down at the bottom that like you stab
yourself on it's like cuz he [ __ ]
knows what's down there
he's like also this water is full of
[ __ ] diseases because everybody's
been pissing in it like cuz all the men
have to piss in them why and so he's
like so you could get a [ __ ]
dysentery or whatever [ __ ]
contaminate your water yeah so the guy
was like uhm but something interesting
did come of it so he's like so I decided
he's like I'm still gonna do it he's
like but they told me I probably
shouldn't do it drunk because I only
have one guy and it's like I don't know
if he can pull me out and [ __ ] so he
actually did go there and he just threw
himself into the canal he checked the
depths and everything like that first
and an interesting thing happened as
soon as
threw himself into the canal it was only
three feet like by the wall and [ __ ]
like that
he it was so cold that it took his
breath away yeah and he was like like he
came up because he could swim and stuff
he came up and he couldn't talk for
several seconds and he said that when he
researched it he's like when you jump
into water this cold it's your [ __ ]
you know your what's your breathing tube
called your [ __ ] tres or whatever
yours your tricky is right that it just
kind of closes up because it's trying to
get it's trying to protect like your
brain and like your vital organs and
stuff so it's trying to like you know
keep that to keep you from like dying
really even though it's probably gonna
kill you faster but he's like so
interestingly he's like me jumping into
the canal he's like expecting it he's
like - I was sober three it was daytime
and he's like even then I found that he
got out like obviously he's like because
it wasn't that deep and you know he
could just climb out but he's like can
you imagine if it was pitch black if you
were pissed blind drunk and you fell in
the water and he was like the water was
actually like way way way way colder cuz
he did like the temperature on it then
what would cause hypothermia to begin
you know what I mean yeah so he's like
had I stayed in this water I would have
died and died of hypothermia so you can
see like him just jumping in there and
he's like and I was expecting to jump in
you know what I mean so if you were just
like really drunk trying to walk home or
something I prepared you're not really
prepared and it's dark you slip or
something what if it's a little bit
deeper yeah well in the middle it is cuz
he cuz he noted he's like most of the
canals it's like they're only about 20
feet I'm talking about the guys that
fell in and died yeah what if they fell
in at places where the it was a lot
deeper yeah they fell it maybe if it was
six feet or seven feet yeah I meant
where you couldn't stand up well he said
that he said what they are all like and
he's like I don't know if all the canals
are like this but most of them are like
this cuz most of them are from the
Victorian era and they made them all
pretty much the same way he's like right
there by the wall it's three feet you
can stand up but then it slopes yeah and
he's like when you get into the middle
it's too you can't stand up in yeah it's
six seven eight feet far away from the
bank
is it not very far like what we're
talking did five feet six feet yeah
maybe
okay so that's a Z yeah if you got yeah
yeah that momentum the next thing you
know you're in the deep part you can't
stand up and like I said if it did it's
cold it's dark you're drunk as [ __ ]
you're drunk as [ __ ] you can't see what
if you get like disorientated yet you
gasp and take in some water and then
you're [ __ ] gagging and choking and
your head goes underneath the water
that's it you're [ __ ] gone that's
what it means
so I think it happened fast I feel like
that could happen really really easily
like I said that could happen when
you're sober like what if you're just
like well it's like even if it was a
girl for example where she's like trying
to walk in high heels and she just slips
and falls in and nobody's around and
this guy was saying he's like even
though I'm sober and it's daytime and
everything like that he's like I fell in
you know he's like I jumped in he's like
but I couldn't talk for several so it's
like if I was trying to scream for help
I couldn't because it was so cold that
it just like constricted his airway now
you know I told stories many times you
know the man being my dad being from
Mississippi and growing up in the
summers in Mississippi all the time and
me being born in California my aunt take
me up the Sierra Nevada mountains up in
[ __ ] redwood forests all the time you
know we had bad ass [ __ ] rivers apart
they were ice-cold water
mossy rocks lots of [ __ ] Rapids we
had fun
naked teenage girls run around and read
all the [ __ ] story it was it was from
another era that's gone back to the 70s
people just don't understand how
dangerous water is yeah along those
river banks there was signs saying be
careful with pitchers black and white
pitchers on the sides of drought dead
bodies floating back it's hardcore yeah
yeah back in those days where they
didn't play yeah and they usually had
those around wherever there was a
waterfall yeah those people like to go
over the waterfalls of course these are
huge waterfalls because the water was
like [ __ ] seven feet deep going over
a waterfall and like a twenty or thirty
foot drop down into a [ __ ] water
all basin that might have been 4050 feet
deep you know I mean [ __ ] and then the
revit river kept on going no we'd go
over you just let you know that what you
were doing was dangerous
like a look we're washing our hands yeah
yeah yeah we'd go over them anyway and
it would what was weird is that you'd go
over and sometimes the waterfall would
press down on you for a few minutes you
couldn't float back up so yeah it took a
while for me that would scare me [ __ ] to
bounce and Bob all right around a little
bit and then sometimes you'd come up and
when you come up you were under the
waterfall not outside of it like under
the cliff yeah and you're oh [ __ ] and
you had to take a breath and then
[ __ ] dive back under and go through
all that again to end up on the other
side of the waterfall so the rapids
could take you away thank you yeah we
were doing that one I was doing that
when I was [ __ ] young that's part of
the reason why I'm [ __ ] crazy because
you know the seventies and back in the
seventies we was a kid in the 70s too
but I'm not crazy we were [ __ ] feral
you know I mean we didn't have
helicopter parents that said don't do
this don't do that they were like yeah
get the [ __ ] out of there okay yeah they
were kind of like sick okay come back
when you get the ark yeah so funs be
quiet so I think I think the people that
are talking about this and we're are
city people who do not have an
experience with [ __ ] water
well it's Amelia water is [ __ ]
dangerous seeing the way that this is
set up yeah it just in fact I'm
surprised that it doesn't happen more
often because like I said literally in a
lot of these places yes they're like
boat locks there's all this other kind
of stuff and yes there's railings in
some of the places but they're a little
they're literally being like a whole
Street of bars like about 10 12 feet of
pavement in a canal yeah there's no
railing there's no nothing it's like
you're [ __ ] drunk and you're in
clothes warm and dry yeah taking a nice
comfortable piss all this nice
comfortable piss off the side down into
the water to contaminate somebody else's
[ __ ] large and without warning your
ass [ __ ] slips and falls both [ __ ]
your ass your ass hits the [ __ ]
ground
and then you fall in and your head hits
the [ __ ] side on the way down I can
totally see they're in the [ __ ] cold
water and you didn't expect it you know
I mean and you're gasping and breathing
in [ __ ] water and you're drought
you're out with on the end and before
you know it and you're just a body now I
was doing all that dangerous [ __ ] as a
little kid with my aunt's and my uncles
and I mean [ __ ] like that and all the
teenage naked girls the [ __ ] that were
running around but we knew what we were
we were mentally prepared yeah to go
into ice-cold [ __ ] Rapids yeah that's
what I mean and to go over waterfalls
and [ __ ] like that you know man and it
was that water was cold but it wasn't
cold outside yeah yeah I mean so and we
weren't wearing clothes just wearing
like swimming trunks yeah says if you're
what if you get wet you know that you
know just like okay your [ __ ] clothes
are heads if shoes I'm and you try to
struggle your way out and you're not
getting any warmer when you get out of
the water it's [ __ ] cold as your
clothes are now [ __ ] cold yeah so
hypothermia and shock can set in fast I
think yeah and like like this guy when
he just jumped into the canal and they
did the he said look hypothermia starts
to set in at 21 degrees Celsius um he's
like he just put the pole like the the
thermometer like in the canal for like
literally like maybe five seconds 11
degrees Celsius that's how cold that
[ __ ] water was and he said look he's
like I fell in he's like and I know and
I knew I was going in and it was daytime
and I'm sober and even then he's like
yes even though I got out easily but it
was still like it was so cold that it
just took his breath away the mind has a
lot to do with it
yeah if you're not mentally prepared for
something you can be overwhelmed
mentally by yeah damn you very early and
I think that's partly what's happened I
think that's what that's especially when
they're drunk yeah if you're [ __ ]
drunk that compounds it because
interestingly one thing that happened in
a lot of these cases not all of them but
it did seem like a significant
proportion of them the people the dudes
would go missing after they'd been
kicked out of a bar
yeah I kind of feel like if you hear cut
out of a bar you must in England yeah oh
you're then you must either be on drugs
yeah or really really [ __ ] up now some
of these some of these people may have
been drugged by other people there is
like like I said some evidence to
suggest that but you have to I feel like
you have to be pretty messed up well
even in the United States you have to be
pretty messed up that's causing a lot of
trouble that's that's all sealing the
deal for me having a wide range of
experience with [ __ ] cold water you
know from an early age and [ __ ]
alcohol the booze and military
experience you know in the infantry
that's what's happening to them they're
shit-faced [ __ ] drunk
taking a piss they fall in the water
totally unprepared for it maybe they hit
their head on the way down maybe not
but still the shock of that hitting that
cold water I mean yeah ashes
it just sends them even if you could
yeah it sends it sends them [ __ ] you
know I mean into a [ __ ] mental zone
and it just snaps the will right out of
them and sometimes when you're like
really really drunk you don't even
really [ __ ] know what's going here
you don't really care what's going yeah
it's like whatever or some about
hardship it can SAP the will out of you
and that yeah freezing cold just ah yeah
I can totally see that it and it would
happen like really really real fast yeah
it would happen really quickly and
honestly some of these guys probably
aren't even taking a piss and I'm not
saying some of them haven't got pushed
in by people that were trying to bug
them or people that were just maybe
someone were peeing and somebody thought
it would be funny to be like it it just
no it's the water because they see a
reflection on the surface it could be
something that simple babji yeah
you're not thinking right and then you
hit and it [ __ ] instantly
incapacitate you and you just you know
lose it yeah because some of these were
like you said we're in the wintertime
and I've seen some pictures of the canal
the wintertime it has like [ __ ] ice
floating in it so it would be it would
be the equivalent of falling into a
[ __ ] fire mm-hmm remember that dude
you see the video that dude at the
Burning Man who ran into the bonfire oh
yeah
yeah I wonder what he experienced and
the whole crowds whoa I mean did he feel
that depends on what ran right into that
damn fire I guess it depends on what
truck made it suicide yeah that was for
huge bonfire I wonder if he really knew
what he was doing or if you just might
think he did I think he just wanted to
go out and he wanted to [ __ ] I get it as
soon as I brought everybody to see it so
he ran right into the bonfire and
[ __ ] the song go right into those
flames yeah I could imagine he says I
mean he was just as a dead run went
right into it underneath there I'd
imagine he just every bit of [ __ ]
skin just peeled right off of him
probably did it did he take a deep
breath imagine what that would do to you
that's okay you just start screaming and
ah damn it man it's like if you want to
go do it yourself I feel like there's
nicer ways to go about it than that and
plus not having to traumatize everybody
else that was around having to see that
[ __ ] selfish maybe if you're just
mentally [ __ ] prepared for it maybe
it's not painful maybe that's and maybe
if you're on drugs there's a certain
amount of that's what I'm saying like
maybe it was like a drug thing I read
this thing about a Buddhist it's like an
old Buddhist [ __ ] story about a some
guy who wouldn't submit to some King and
he was a Buddhist the King [ __ ]
ordered him cut into pieces joint by
joint starting with his [ __ ] fingers
and his toes and he relished each each
dismemberment as if it was a [ __ ]
gift and down to where he was nothing
but just a stump with a head and maybe
them as the death yeah it's like
whatever I loved it well he'd just stay
you know he just stayed at peace with
himself you know my man decided he
wasn't kind of [ __ ] give in to the
[ __ ] tyrant the mind is a powerful
[ __ ] thing it is indeed no I'd be
like yeah King whatever you said your
power only extends a few twenty twenty
thirty miles outside the city whatever
you say goes sneak out later I don't
understand these people yeah what's a
finger or two gets cut off yeah I feel
like yeah it kind of sucks I don't
really yeah
you got a keg you the man well that's
kind of more my style I just I just kind
of like pretend I'm going along with
whatever and then I disappear but I just
all right so do you want to take a break
in this take a break this will come back
I think we pretty much just I think we
pretty much solved this one I think it's
statistical and accidents and it's I
think there's like a like I said I'm
sure of a handful of them are probably
crimes are happened in yeah murder
crimes muggings things like that but
they're not connected but I don't think
they're connected to one another and I
think largely they are probably
accidents and it's seeing the canals in
pictures and videos and stuff like that
um it seems like it could happen really
really easily is one thing so yeah we're
gonna take a break right now when we
come back we're gonna talk about the
Sufi Lancaster case and we're also going
to talk about Angus Sinclair and the
World's End murders so we'll be back in
just a couple of minutes
[Applause]
Oh looky look at pokey she is living in
the closet still looking for that lizard
oh my god oh my God look it uh-huh look
at this face look at this me well here's
this little belly
look at her little drumsticks yeah you
done doing that okay look your butt
there you go let's start filming her
she's like I'm gonna lick my butt now
yeah okay you get on with that you love
true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
okay we're back on this UK crime show so
talked about the Manchester pusher
before um also wanted to cover on this
half of the show first thing I wanted to
cover was the murder of Sophie Lancaster
now I've had several requests for this
in fact one of them came just a couple
of days ago and I was like hey you're in
luck because because I'm already like
scheduled to talk about this this case
and I remember when this happened it was
in 2007 and I think a lot of us related
to this case in particular because this
was a case where a couple was attacked
just at random by a bunch of teenagers
that was such disdain well that's that's
generally how children in general
everybody when this [ __ ] went down man I
was [ __ ] seeing red I was in my
[ __ ] late 20s when I should I think a
lot of people were a lot of people yeah
and I was like I'd kill them [ __ ] all
right good yeah that's kind of the thing
so um one good thing it's kind of weird
to say that but like one good thing that
came out of this was that at least a lot
of people became more aware of because
of the media behind this case and like
you know the big outcry about it about
how people who look different get
targeted by these gangs it's like moving
feral children yeah we're here in
England and what's funny is like I
remember this era we've talked about
this before
you know we talked about this with
remember when remember with those
murders that happened with the goth kids
that killed the religious family and all
the [ __ ] that went down you know and I
was [ __ ] in New Orleans working on
convergence and [ __ ] like that anyway
this was a time and when where there was
a pretty strong goth scene you know
these people were all in their 50s and
40s now you don't I mean so funny
they're [ __ ] grown-up adults although
some of them are still got I gave it
anyway
they're all in their 40s and 50s now but
back in the day we had our own seen in
our own look and really we were [ __ ]
normal compared to a lot of people bezel
yeah we were normal compared to [ __ ]
jocks oh yeah okay but Marilyn Manson
came on the scene and was doing it by
wind was doing a bunch of [ __ ]
outrageous things and based on Marilyn
Manson [ __ ] mundanes I call it we I
call it a mundanes at those times and
it's a racial slur against people who
are now gothic but the Mondays started
[ __ ] with us because they thought we
were all Marilyn Manson yeah when I was
like what the [ __ ] is this dude who's
this Marilyn Manson guy you know and I
really wasn't into it you know holy [ __ ]
I remember and I remember this
distinctly and this was probably back in
the late 90s early 2000s I'm in line
waiting to go to the [ __ ] castle in
Tampa yeah and these [ __ ] normal as
people these Karen's are yeah Becky's
mundanes yeah when I call them they were
like a couple people in line in front of
me and you could tell because there was
always a handful that would come like
slumming and they just like hey let's go
out and look at the freaks at this yeah
over here and you know and every
everybody knew about it and they just
felt like oh yeah there's always a
handful they were always different at
that time I was in Boston they weren't
allowed in they didn't pass them I
always bought I know dress code [ __ ]
I always wanted to counsel that a dress
code but they will do it but um yeah
just to keep those people out so because
those people would come in and
immediately they cause trouble it's like
they did it they couldn't help
themselves they come in and start
groping one of the dancers the castle's
a [ __ ] big goth club here in [ __ ]
Florida in Tampa
been there forever they actually talked
about it on Saturday night Saturday
Night Live they did a goth talk [ __ ]
they had I'm talking about the
difference between Orlando it's right
it's right and we're in the [ __ ]
Orlando Tampa [ __ ] thing now but it's
funny because now we do all the graphics
for the DJ sonal at all these clubs it's
funny yeah I did all the poster
we're friends with them all so we go to
all that [ __ ] but back in those days man
they used to [ __ ] with us about how we
looked and they made all these weird
yeah these normal people in light of the
cavern hey Marilyn Manson that what that
is [ __ ] we don't like what they said and
they said it like they were like
announcing it like who's them like yeah
[ __ ] are you talking about
we're like dad you'd really had nothing
to do with the scene yeah though I'm
like I've been dressing like this since
the 80s yeah my friend actually kind of
came up with him Demetri because Marilyn
Manson's from here he's from Florida yes
yes and Dimitri was a deejay at [ __ ]
the local club that [ __ ] we support
do all the all the [ __ ] flyers and
all promotion for us he knew Marilyn
Manson before he was Marilyn mass and he
was Brian when he was Brian okay so he
he is a local guy you know we we know
I'm think he's born here but he lived
here he lived around here so we know the
people that came out with him I ran into
him in New Orleans down the French
Quarter him and [ __ ] dude from 1910
Reznor yeah I got stories about boats
she's laughing because she knows us
nervous it weren't allowed into the
[ __ ] club that one of these clubs
they scooter was a private club called
the convent which was the [ __ ]
speakeasy it didn't have a [ __ ] like
a liquor license all right Jerry
Springer was [ __ ] hanging out in
there all time and Jerry Springer you
guys don't know if [ __ ] Jerry
Springer was [ __ ] awesome me and
Jerry Springer were [ __ ] watching a
[ __ ] fetish show going on and it was
between a husband and a wife and it was
private it was just for me and Jerry
[ __ ] I was having a goddamn out-of-body
experience all right man Jerry Springer
watching this it anyway that was that
was back in the days that was back in
the days when the goth industrial scene
was a very underground private [ __ ]
scene it was cool dudes and goth
strippers that in their boyfriends and
goth chicks
and then this Marilyn Manson dude came
and made all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
mainstream that's what I mean you've
ruined and that's not what the scene was
it didn't have anything to do with that
he was mainstream when he appeared it's
kind of like how I blame Nirvana for
[ __ ] up the punk [ __ ] alternative
rock exactly that's a good analogy I
like and I like Nirvana's music I'm just
saying it and it probably wasn't their
fault that that [ __ ] that nevermind
was like a huge hit but I remember
distinctly the time before nevermind
came out yeah the time after never made
for me God started in Detroit back in
the 80s
after I [ __ ] came back from [ __ ]
Brazil and was hanging out with my high
school friends that when I was in
because I went to high school in two
different places when I was in trend
misc and it was hanging out [ __ ] the
shelter in Detroit and st. Andrews Hall
if you look in the majestic theatre if
you look at the first and last and
always album from [ __ ] Sisters of
Mercy that was taken right outside the
majestic theatre the inner sleeve but
this is diversity that was a scene I
came from and it was a it was a
different time it was about Skinny Puppy
from across the [ __ ] way you know
with Kevin Key and all those guys nice
to run into the [ __ ] Skinny Puppy at
at [ __ ] City Club and it [ __ ]
there was no place called industry was
in Canada and then it was [ __ ] the city
club and then there was the [ __ ] in the
shelter and I used to see those guys in
there and I wasn't cool enough to hang
out with him now those [ __ ] super
super famous there was another band
called kitty with a whip
that was a [ __ ] I blew my [ __ ]
mind and that was before we had all this
technology yet I mean there were no home
computers and for me that's where it
started I don't know why I went down
this [ __ ] path just talking about the
evolution of that [ __ ] thing and
throwing up in it it's relevant because
what's relevant about what happened
these [ __ ] jack holes jumping on a
random British girl who would look it
was a shuffle yeah yeah her boyfriend
just happened not to
right yeah and they just look cool as
[ __ ] to me they're just like regular
people that would [ __ ] I'd see at the
[ __ ] Club and they got sure about
that weird looking I don't think I
didn't think so either I was like and
these [ __ ] [ __ ] jumped on these
these this couple and beat one of them
to death this cute [ __ ] girl for just
looking cool and she didn't really look
any like if I were to say like his lost
lymph out straight he's not strange to
me no that was nothing compared to what
we were wearing for [ __ ] Boston in the
90s it [ __ ] great that's a [ __ ] Man
Ray and the night they got attacked her
boyfriend was just wearing like a hoodie
and jeans yeah and she was just wearing
normal clothes
I mean the only thing like they had a
couple of facial piercings like they had
their snakebite piercings yeah and she
had like dreads but that's about it they
didn't they weren't like all decked out
like fetish or anything like that they
were just like going they'd been at a
pub or something and they were just like
going back home they're just lucky that
they didn't run into me all right at
that time I was a [ __ ] just out of
the military as [ __ ] crazy as [ __ ]
civilian I was carrying guns at that
time and I was carrying dirty I'm gonna
be honest this is before I started
getting into the [ __ ] that I later got
into working for clique the state police
and doing stuff post-service you know I
mean I was carrying dirty back then had
they jumped on me and seemed like my
first wife or one of my ex-girlfriends
day would have been nothing but bullet
holes killed every one of them back then
alright and they're lucky you think
anyone would have blamed you I would
admit it clean getaway and then
everything still be looking for me yeah
you know they're lucky that that was
England cuz yes she would not fly
anywhere here in the United States no
well I kind of feel like okay so this is
what happened this happened in 2007
so Sophie Lancaster she was born in 1986
she was actually planning on going she
hadn't gone to college yet but she was
planning on going to college for English
her boyfriend was named Robert Maltby he
was
twenty-one years old and he was an art
student in Manchester they had been
going out for three years
by all accounts were talking about the
future they were very serious they lived
together and everything like that so
they're walking home on August 11th 2007
like I said they just kind of been out
in the town or whatever like out of
power whatever and they were walking
home about one o'clock in the morning
now from what I understand I thought at
first they were walking through like or
past like a skate park or something
we're like a lot of other teenagers like
hung out and I thought that a group of
girls like approached them and we're
like I don't know if they were like
saying oh you guys look cool or
something like that or they were just
trying to like bum cigarettes off them
or whatever but they seemed like really
friendly so they were kind of like
talking to them and like giving him a
cigarette or whatever and then all of a
sudden um this was a in case I didn't
mention it this was in Bakke up which is
in Lancashire hope I'm pronouncing that
right I saw a documentary about it that
was how they pronounced his folks that's
right so this then this group of boys I
don't know if the group of boys was
associated with a group of girls like if
the girls had got them to come over
there like to lure them or whatever or
if the or if it was just like a
coincidence because like I said this was
a skate park and a lot of teenagers hung
out there so they might not have been it
might have been like a setup or anything
but so this gang of teenagers started
following Sophie and Robert and then
they just it was like five of them and
then they jumped on them beat Robert
Moll be unconscious and this [ __ ]
this detail like [ __ ] broke my heart
right so Robert Mulvey is beaten
unconscious Sophie wraps her body around
him to protect him and then the boys
start kicking the [ __ ] out of her too
it's just unimaginable to me
unimaginable that can you imagine no I
totally say they were just like kicking
her head like it was a [ __ ] football
unimaginable to me just random I don't
understand how that could happen in the
yeah like what the [ __ ] is this and like
when and when these kids like went to
trial like one of the judge said
something like you he said something
like your [ __ ] I can't even report he
said it was like some court is like
you're just [ __ ] like not even human
or like nothing like that it's like this
is he called them like feral animals
yeah yeah I would have to meet how many
a were there there were five of them I
would if they know of I would make five
brain slushies yeah no excuse for it
would all be a [ __ ] point-blank range
and you know and I'm not I'm not in to
[ __ ] take it out on our [ __ ]
you know I mean but in a situation like
that I think in this situation it's
justified yeah kids are 15 years old
that is old enough to have no say 15 15
years old another John that is old
enough 15 I knew that that was not good
to do there have been that's not that
yeah thousands and thousands of African
boy soldiers younger than 15 that have
died for much less
you don't talking about yeah that's big
enough to die like I said you know
that's a [ __ ] desert
these are helpless civilians yeah and
you've attacked them and they're just
like walking they didn't do anything to
anybody they were just like walking home
and these particular 15 year old kids
just thought they looked funny or
thought look they thought they looked
weird and thought hey we're just gonna
kick the [ __ ] out of them and they just
thought it was beating to death and they
just thought it was hilarious yeah so
yet so the thing about it so one of the
there were a bunch of other kids at the
park too because for a time the police
were looking into maybe arresting more
people because they didn't know if more
people were involved or if more people
were just like watching and do anything
or there was some other [ __ ] going on
like five people ended up being
convicted but they didn't know if they
didn't have enough evidence to like
convict anybody else one of the one
fifteen-year-old kid did call for an
ambulance and the the call said units
999
over there it's not 911 1 but he said
and this is a quote we need an ambulance
at Baker park this MA sure has just been
banged because he's a ma sure that's
what they call them for whatever reason
I never heard that term but ok yeah so
later on some of the people that had
done it and like I said this is another
reason for just like [ __ ] wiping these
[ __ ] off the face of the earth
because some of the people that had been
involved in the crime
later on brag to their friends that they
had done something good and they also
told people at the scene there's two
Mosher's nearly dead a bake up park you
want to see them they're a right mess
they just thought it was funny yeah they
just thought it was [ __ ] funny yeah
those dudes probably end up in [ __ ]
prison and then [ __ ] years later
they're like what the [ __ ] was I
thinking
they probably didn't even think that
maybe I still think it's funny because
up because dudes like that I feel like
they don't grow out of that you know
what I mean I just feel like they don't
you know what's funny though I think
about this and I'm trying to think do we
have people like that here in the yes
States yes we do yes but how many how
many times does this actually happened
in the United remember to tell you the
last time [ __ ] anybody ever said any
[ __ ] to me we were [ __ ] decked out
ready to go to the club was over the
[ __ ] gas station over 7-eleven and it
was a long crew [ __ ] burly
[ __ ] with all ideas just tell
me how awesome I looked manage it it's
changed like it's much better because
like back in the put on a show for them
yeah they're like were the [ __ ] way
dressed like that this is why I'm going
I'm hosting the club now Oh yo strum the
club say yo
then they wanted to dance the [ __ ] and
that's not the way it was back in the
90s no not the way it was not they
didn't get it well in the 80s and 90s
there was no you know in a way I guess
we can thank anyway I guess I guess even
though actually it broke through even
though he kind of like powered through
it but yeah in the 80s and 90s you have
to understand that a lot of people
didn't have any frame of reference right
they didn't know what it was they didn't
know what it was so they just thought I
mean what
in high school everyone just called me a
Satanist which I thought yes which I
thought was left over from the satanic
panic but now I mean I was a girl so
what I mean I got bullied a lot but I
didn't get physically beat up however
several of my male friends did get
physically beat for wearing eyeliner or
having Robert Smith hair or something
like that it happened quite often so you
know and and my brother was kind of he
was in a punk band so that we were kind
of like all hung out with like the punks
and [ __ ] too and there was a lot of [ __ ]
going on there too because in DeLand
which was only about 20 or 30 miles from
where I grew up there was a large
skinhead contingent so every time there
was a punk show they would all come over
and start fights with people there were
skinheads in Florida yeah didn't know
that yeah a Nazi skinheads whole nine
yards they were up in Boston [ __ ] the
[ __ ] white laces on boots and the
[ __ ] up in Boston the land there was
like for some reason that was like a big
group of him into land and every time
you would have a punk show in Daytona
and like I said I went to all the punk
shows in Daytona because my brother was
in a punk band and he like open for a
lot of bands there and so every time
you'd have a [ __ ] show you'd have
this [ __ ] group of [ __ ] turning
up doing their little Nazi salutes and
all that other kind of crap and then
they would have to get their ass beat
which they usually did who happily buy
the other punks like it's gonna say
turned up everybody's like alright here
we go
we had those in Boston but they weren't
really a big deal not to me yeah well
like I said it just gets it gets
tiresome you have these losers like turn
it up at every show and you can't like
enjoy the show
because you know and it's like some band
that doesn't have any so we're not going
to see [ __ ] screwdriver or anything
like that it's just like a regular house
punk band and you get this [ __ ]
contingent of like 10 or 15 stupid ass
[ __ ] show it up good like Heil
Hitler and sure it's like you know what
I had skin has trying to beat my ass
buff in Boston but it didn't they
weren't Nazi skinheads and didn't have
anything to do with [ __ ] me being
gothic it was the fact that I ran off of
the [ __ ] band with it with the leader
of the bands [ __ ] girlfriend
well the guy's name is Paul Bearer he's
called the name of Anna's sheer terror
and [ __ ] he was dangerous yeah it was
good van I liked it but I ran out for
this girlfriend and then with Lisa you
literally ran off oh yeah I had to
[ __ ] take it
I had to take it was available I had to
take it it was a girlfriend here yeah
and then next thing you know I had about
twenty or thirty [ __ ] skinheads
running after you but I disappeared off
into the goth club's they would they
were they wouldn't dare follow me there
they couldn't didn't have eyeliner well
I guess because I grew up I mean I grew
up in Daytona and so and sometimes
Orlando when I could get over there
but so in Daytona there were so few
weirdos that like all the Goths and
punks and alternative rock people you
just all hung out together because there
was only like a few of us so we were
like man we got to stick together I
don't care if you like punkin no I got
and you're picking on me even we didn't
hang out with some hippies and [ __ ] like
that just if you're a weirdo like you
just kind of hung out all together
well the way I hit it I started off in
Detroit and you got to be a weird
[ __ ] to even hang out in Detroit
and every white boy in Detroit was
[ __ ] weird
all right they had all kinds of
gangbangers I'd find dead bodies in the
[ __ ] dumpster out and back behind my
apartment all the time for the feet
sticking out you know but as long as you
were a white boy they wouldn't [ __ ] with
you they just wouldn't I have no beef
there's no beef you have you had I got
along with every [ __ ] brother who's up
there you know but they were killing
each other behind the dope gang yeah I
said they didn't have any beat there you
have any beef with me but then I ended
up going to Boston and then like you
said you got skinheads you got and then
you had Goths and then you had college
students and [ __ ] like that and it was
it was a big [ __ ] but I don't
knows all right I was trying to I was
trying to put it to words there's no way
it was just another time it was and I
don't I don't want to end up being one
of those old people that yeah you know
that that talks about like old old hippy
days and stuff like my you know parents
and stuff used to do but
I don't know now later on when I moved
when I later on when I moved back to
Mississippi hanging out with my dad and
then partying in Louisiana before the
other [ __ ] happened before I was with
state police stuff
Louisiana was losing the way New Orleans
was cool in the French Quarter was cool
because he never knew who you're gonna
run into is running into people from all
over the world that I knew already
yes I'd run into Goths from Boston legit
but they did have some [ __ ]
knuckleheads running through there yeah
I mean they wanted to just just wanted
to get drunk up the [ __ ] French
Quarter yeah knuckleheads but still that
is [ __ ] cool me and Jerry Springer
watching a [ __ ] Fast Show private
fast show me and the [ __ ] dude dude
not a lot of people smacking on his wife
with the [ __ ] riding crop and [ __ ]
I'm at the [ __ ] convent yeah Pierre
in the cages castle guy guy who ran it
was nearly name was Pierre yeah yeah
Pierre look like something out of
[ __ ] interview with the vampires
we're in roll 17 Hertz closed a long
hair and [ __ ] his wife had let you in
had a gate and [ __ ] how do you know
about this place I heard about you guys
on the Internet
this is back when the internet was new
oh hey come on in you come on it what
club did you come from I'm just coming
from the fun I'm coming from [ __ ] man
right it's gone now Oh Boston yet come
on in see that's kind of like like I
said that is kind of why I wish and like
I said this we were a community back
then listen little germane to this case
to you like because I always wished for
that very reason because of the
knucklehead invasion that you are I
always wish that the castle had a dress
code yeah the only time that I went cuz
Florida for some reason like a lot of
clubs here don't want to do that it's
like oh no we want to make the money and
it's like so we have to let all these
[ __ ] jerks and that are just coming in
to like castle had bouncers though lots
of them they did yet and um the only
time that I ever went to somewhere that
had like a really strict dress code was
a place called Man Ray which was in Fort
Lauderdale oh you had a man ray in Fort
Lauderdale indeed okay and I went there
a couple of times and they had I don't
know if they had it all the time but
they had like pretty frequent like big
fetish parties and you it was
very strict I mean you didn't like if
you're just wearing like jeans or just
right regular pants or like nope you had
to be like it was like fetish gear or
full-on god [ __ ] or you judge a
[ __ ] by their boots their boots
and their shoes the shoes it gives it
away it gives it away I don't know if
it's I don't know if it's like that so
much nowadays but up until the 2000s at
least you could always tell because even
if they had like some clothes that
looked all right and [ __ ] like that you
can always be like yeah okay wrong brand
which makes us sound like really [ __ ]
bad like really yeah but it's but it's
not well it's just out cold well it's
because it's a subculture and you get a
lot of people coming in like in a
costume yeah they don't look like that
all the time right but they're in
costumes that maybe that was just our
clothes that was just our full dress
clothes I mean you know we looked
obviously you know I don't dress up like
that every day because it's a pain in
the ass I don't want to wear a corset
every day but it's like that [ __ ] that
we wear regularly and when you get like
some you know Kelly or Becky or Karen
like turning up who's usually like some
Account Manager with like the [ __ ]
can I see your manager hair and she was
like decided to like goth out because
she has to like wait and it's like you
get a lot of that it's very very common
so you would get that so you very
quickly like learn to recognize and some
of them could pass mostly but every
single one of them even if they did all
this [ __ ] up here good this shows what
all these are wrongs we're always wrong
always ya understand we wear expensive
shoes and there's a couple different
particular types of shoes pneumonia okay
that's the entry-level all right and
then and then there's [ __ ] what's
that [ __ ] that a new rock new rock is
the [ __ ] that's what I got that's if you
got money okay this is a $350 pair of
books but they last forever though
there's three $350 pair of [ __ ] boots
but this all leather it's all the real
beautiful and they'll last for 30
[ __ ] years I mean you can tell that
they just went to like journeys or
something yeah awesome and just
got like some knee-high black boots and
I'm like that's just like that's a $20
not well it's not just that how much
they cost it's how they look it's like
I'm just like that cut not alright gonna
cut it that's just not gonna work
so yeah so getting back to the Sophie
Lancaster case so these [ __ ]
teenagers kick these poor people to
death right to death and you know yeah
her in her case at least so the police
get there because one of the 15 year
olds did actually have the presence of
mind to call an ambulance you know I'm
like the other ones who just thought it
was [ __ ] funny I guess
so the cops get there and they remarked
that the faces were so swollen that they
couldn't tell which what gender they
were dan you know I mean like that's how
because they were just these kids were
just literally like they were
unconscious the two of them were
unconscious and they were just kept like
stepping on kicking their heads
yeah it's unimaginable how unimaginable
who does that I'm like who [ __ ] does
that Psychopaths people that need to be
[ __ ] put down like Mad Dogs yeah yeah
like yeah no I'm saying they're lucky
that they're lucky I wasn't there
oh yeah so I wouldn't I wouldn't have
[ __ ] put up with that [ __ ] like I
said what do you put a Mississippi heat
on those [ __ ] they wouldn't
they wouldn't know they wouldn't have
understood it England doesn't understand
what Mississippi can do we're [ __ ]
stupid we're a much stupider than
anything we're Afghanistan stupid we're
all right it's true kind of stupid to
terrorize a [ __ ] but yes so now
both Sophie and her boyfriend were still
alive while they were at the park so
they were both transported by ambulance
obviously to the hospital
now Robert Maltby was in a coma
Sophie Lancaster was also no coma
however Sofie she was in a coma for a
very for a couple of weeks and they had
determined at one point that she was
brain dead so her parents had yeah a
huge tragedy this turn off her life
support there's a huge tragedy this girl
but from what I remember I haven't seen
her in [ __ ] 20 30 years cute as a bug
cute as a bug well and both of them were
by all accounts and and I read a review
an interview with Robert Mulvey who
didn't really give a lot of interviews
after understandably after he recovered
he did give a brief one to The Guardian
on the 10th anniversary which was 2017
and to be honest with you he sounds like
a lovely human being yeah and honestly
it's it just makes me so sad like the
[ __ ] that he said I wanted to like quote
some of it it's like I don't know
because I was like reading it and I was
like man we're gonna be here a way
better person than I am because he
basically said he's like well he's like
he doesn't want his whole life because
he survived I mean he was in a coma for
a long time he lost his memory of the
incident obviously his girlfriend was
horribly murdered imagine a bunch of
survivor's guilt he couldn't protect her
but no but Matt come on math five versus
one the hard way well yeah and and he
seems to have had a really hard time
after that like you know what I mean he
you know obviously went into therapy he
would had to be on a presence for a long
time which like I said completely
understandable cuz it's like a [ __ ]
horrible situation that nobody should
have to go through and the fact that he
can come out later and he's an artist
he's had like exhibitions and things
like that and he said a couple things
he's like well in a way I don't like
that the media portrayed it as you know
we got attacked because we were Goths or
because we looked like Goths
he's like you know it's kind of true but
he's like I think it kind of he's like
it kind of sucks because they didn't
know Sophie he's like they didn't know
and he said like a couple things he's
like they didn't know like how she took
her
coffee they didn't know how they didn't
know anything about her they just knew
that that's what she looked like and
that was kind of like having me do you
want to play it and he's like so they
kind of simplified it he's like and I
also kind of felt like he's like I felt
like it was a little bit of
victim-blaming
he's like in a way because I remember
yeah he's like because it was almost
it's not like the media was saying oh
they deserve to get their ass kicked
because it look like that but he's like
because they focus so much yeah on how
they look on how we looked and he's like
and they in that particular night they
didn't really they weren't wearing
anything is that outlandish or weird or
I mean even if they were it's obviously
naturally I was there at the time and I
do remember there was kind of coming it
was kind of coming across as
victim-blaming
I I kind of remember that because it had
came across because around this time
period like 2007 like a you know year or
two on the front of back of that there
were a lot of crimes in the UK with like
gangs of teenagers like attacking just
random people for various because they
were gay or because you know they looked
different or something like that so
there was kind of like a little mini
rash of them like right around this time
period and I think that the Sophie
Lancaster case kind of like brought that
to the fore like in a really big way
because I mean her murder as senseless
as it was it really had a kind of an
effect of you know so much support
coming out of not even like just from
the goth committee but from any kind of
like alternative subcultures or you know
any kind of thing like that and you know
there there were even some pushes to
expand the definition of like a hate
crime to encompass people that you know
we're parts of alternative subcultures
or look different or something like that
where because it does seem like that was
the main impetus for the attack because
I mean they were just like walking they
weren't provoking anyone than we're
doing in fact they had like loaned some
of these [ __ ] or at least some
of these other girls at this park
they had loaned them cigarettes prior to
the attack it was completely unprovoked
you know these guys just decided they
looked weird and they were just gonna
like kick their asses and they just
thought it was funny
so and like I said you know coming as it
did like around this time period I
remember there was like a lot of you
know there was a lot of like political
rhetoric there was a lot of like media
attention about you know these teenagers
in Britain and what the [ __ ] is the
matter with them and they're just like
going around like just kicking random
people's asses for being different from
them and yeah we like that was a beard
is that like in the United States we
look like that we look even [ __ ] more
bizarre than that and yeah you get
people [ __ ] yelling at you from
outside their car but they wouldn't
[ __ ] stop and [ __ ] do anything to
you although like I said I did have very
rare that I did have some friends that
got physically really beat up yes okay
well I didn't I didn't have any friends
that really [ __ ] good it was I think
because most of time I was in place
where was too dangerous for them to do
so it seemed to me and like I don't know
if it's like this anymore but when I was
in the going back and forth of the UK I
lived there for you know about six
months seven months at one period but I
went back and forth over there for like
several years and it did seem to me that
there's kind of um a little bit of a
culture of because so many is so much of
they're like evenings and stuff like
that is wrapped up and around drinking
and around pubs and stuff like that so
and it's not illegal to like hang out
like in the streets just drinking you
know in the u.s. you can't really walk
around and drink you kind of have to be
in a bar or just like right outside of
our but they don't really have like real
strict laws about that so I do feel like
there's kind of like a culture like a
laddish kind of culture just like let's
go out to the pub and then let's go beat
the [ __ ] up because my ex-husband who's
British who's Welsh he would tell me
that it's like you know you'd go to a
[ __ ] pub and like the dudes would get
drunk and they'd just be like picking up
glasses and just like breaking him in
girls faces and like [ __ ] like that
there's just like this kind of you know
and they would just like get in fights
he had a relative that actually got
murdered
that way that where they just got in a
fight and just like threw him off a
cliff or some [ __ ] like that so it's
like it does seem like there's kind of
like this yeah it's weird this
undercurrent of they just get drunk and
they just want to fight it's weird
because the United States you know to me
coming up in the scene the most the day
most dangerous city I ever lived in was
Detroit and Detroit is unquestionably
dangerous it was them at that time it
was the murder capital of the of the
United States but for me it was safe I
could walk around goth doubt nobody
would say [ __ ] to me
I was also packing that was carry and
dirty yeah you know I was [ __ ]
packing a [ __ ] I mean yeah but back to
that and if you're in a dangerous area
is not safe to [ __ ] with people it seems
like that but when I moved to Boston
which was a safe [ __ ] place la even
though it was a little more worldly you
would get some sideways [ __ ] glances
every now and then but it wasn't that
bad where it was mostly more aggressive
me down in New Orleans where wasn't
quite as dangerous but [ __ ]
would talk a lot of [ __ ] I never got
attacked though not physically yeah it's
like it's our birthday because it
depends where you are it also depends on
I mean a lot of things to I mean me
being a girl I have a completely
different experience um I never got beat
up but I did get I probably got harassed
a lot more than you did and I also got
like a couple times s I thought I was
gonna get kidnapped a couple of times so
you know there was that whole thing
which a lot of dudes probably don't have
to worry about but see the thing about
it is that I mean women have a thing
where it's like I I don't like to walk
by myself outside anywhere like
especially like downtown in the city and
especially like not goth doubt or
anything I would not I mean I did do
that for a little while like by myself
but I would not advise it even even in
downtown Orlando I usually had friends
and I had people that I knew and [ __ ]
like that in the Detroit era when I was
err lady ATS place is dangerous as [ __ ]
but like I said it was mostly dangerous
for guys in the drug trade wasn't
dangerous for white guys real or just
like a random guy that did nothing but I
was packing yeah I was [ __ ] packed and
I was carrying dirty just the way it was
had you [ __ ] with me back in to try it
out I killed you deader than [ __ ] and
gotten away with it there was no police
service yeah I'm sure one probably
people knew that yeah there's no [ __ ]
police services [ __ ] Mad Max it was it
was nothing but abandoned skyscrapers
and [ __ ] falling down buildings
nobody cared if you killed somebody
there they [ __ ] with you you [ __ ]
deserved it
matter of fact in recent times like back
in what 2010 there were signs going in
and Detroit that you entered Detroit at
your own risk because there's no Police
Service and in in in the 80s you know
that was it was the same way there was
cops but they weren't enforcing any kind
of laws they couldn't they didn't have
the strength they didn't have the money
which I'm sure it's probably like really
alien to somebody in Europe where
there's an idea of law and order there
just wasn't any law or there are still
some places here and particularly I
think a lot of people like you know
especially like more like
african-american communities is it like
that I mean they have long said that you
know we don't even bother calling the
cops they won't come along come right
rail in Detroit when I was there in the
eighties you could walk up to somebody
on the street shoot him five or six
times better than mmm and walk away and
that body would sit there for [ __ ]
days it was sit there for [ __ ] days
yeah which is a totally alien concept to
maybe actually that's an alien concept
of people to most people in the United
States
well yes most of the United States does
not like that well the body would sit
there on the [ __ ] corner for maybe in
two days yeah I don't think most people
in most cities would put up with that
yeah and you know one time I came out of
my [ __ ] dumbbell apartment to get in
my [ __ ] car and I saw feet sticking
up out of the [ __ ] dumpster
and I look you know socks and [ __ ] and
looked in there and there was just some
dead brother damn in there okay he's
dead I even didn't even [ __ ] call the
cops he's got a car wouldn't work cuz
that's what that's what Detroit was yeah
in 1987 88 88 yeah well that's what to
me that's what always seemed very weird
about that was one of the weirdest like
juxtapositions I think yeah and like I
said it might be different now because
I'm you know the time I spent in the UK
was you mostly like mid to late 90s and
um you know I didn't get [ __ ] with or
anything like that like you know I got
cat calls and she like but I get that
over here it wasn't anything different
but there is kind of a culture over
there of you know the whole laddish
culture the whole like pub culture where
they're just like going out getting in
fights that's kind of like their idea of
having a good time so it but it's just
very weird because like then on the
other side of it it's a really civilized
place like a lot of that [ __ ] there's
like [ __ ] like that just doesn't go on
yeah but then there's this kind of like
undercurrent of that type of [ __ ]
wherever there's just like knocking the
[ __ ] out of each other on Saturday night
boys are weird about Detroit and it's
violence is that you're talking about it
an abandoned city that seemed like it
was created a long time ago that no one
lived in and it looked like something
out of Beirut most of it's gone now they
tore it down yeah yeah I mean but that's
just the way it was a little way it was
it was just a different [ __ ] scene so
I can't imagine being in a place like
England and just beating somebody to
death because on the base of what their
[ __ ] looked like and you know I mean
it happens a lot though but that would
like happen in a good area couldn't
happen in a bad area because a bad area
backward when I was coming up was
Detroit and you were afraid to make a
move on somebody unarmed yeah not I mean
that was just the way it was although
yeah anywhere I could walk anywhere look
like a [ __ ] freak and a [ __ ]
although you have to think though that
the that the assailants in this case
were teenagers and teenagers are the
stupidest yes true yeah stupider than
all the animals in the animal kingdom
and I'm including mosquitoes and slugs
in that estimation yeah so and teenage
boys are the worst yeah and the worst it
just it doesn't compute to me I guess
race is a factor too these are white
dudes and then a mostly white said I was
walking around as a white guy in a
mostly black [ __ ] city that was
mostly abandoned and black I'm tell you
black dudes in Detroit were cool to me
well that's what I mean just I wasn't
you don't have anything to do with their
[ __ ] I wasn't in the drug trade I wasn't
fun they were cool to me you know I was
safe so I never had that I always liked
but Jenny knows Jane knows a lot of my
friends today my guy friends are black
guys their military expertise and I just
always kind of had this thing where I
could [ __ ] speak the same language as
a brother you don't know me no [ __ ] I
don't know I never know if it's Detroit
in me or if it's the army or what I
don't know what it is but you know I had
a good time in Detroit
it's just economically depressing
there's no money there well yeah that's
the problem like I'm saying it's like
that's why in a lot of ways like I'm not
saying it's good that there's like all
these like drug-related murders and
stuff like that but in a way you can
understand it because at least there's a
reason behind it they're killing people
because you know hey you [ __ ] me over
on a drug dealer whatever you it's just
like to me it's less understandable no
you're just killing a random purchase
for no that's crazy [ __ ] white boys
that's what I mean that's just crazy I
mean that's what I understand serial
killers on ours and that's why like when
I was right in my face this villain book
I'm like look there's tons of like
unsolved murders where but it was
clearly drug-related and it was kind of
like and I'm not saying that's good I'm
just saying it's not mysterious um
because there's at least a you know and
I hate to use this word but there's at
least a practical reason right or there
is at least a rational reason behind why
you killed that person it's like you
know
they stole my drugs they stole my money
they you know they did something to piss
me off yeah
like I under I get that I just don't get
this kind of like this this lovely
couple that are just like walking they
just went to buy some [ __ ] cigarettes
and they're going back to their house
and then these like gang of teenage
decide oh you guys look a little bit
funny and we're just gonna kick you in
the head and no you die I don't
understand that at all
I just don't why would you do that why
who does that
these [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] white
boys stupid ass [ __ ] I don't I
don't know any brothers that would do
that like that's me it's like why would
you they just try a chat to white girl
up and so like I said teenage boys the
worst and these particular teenage boys
obviously the worst but like I said I
read this interview with Robert Maltby
that came out in 2017 and like I said he
was very you know obviously he's still
upset about it he's moved on he has
another girlfriend and her fiancee who I
believe is American um and he's done
exhibitions and stuff and you know and
he's like you know was talking about the
media being a little bit victim Blamey
which you know I kind of get that and
he's like you know I I kind of wish that
we could focus more on why the killers
did what they did rather than why we got
attacked because we looked different you
know what I mean so which I thought was
a very good point
he also though seemed to be I don't you
didn't like necessarily come out and say
that he forgave the killers but he was
saying well they're teenagers and they
you know it's it's a really economically
depressed area they grew up and really
[ __ ] up circumstances - maybe we
should look into why they turned out
like this rather than focusing on why we
look different and so we got our asses
beat and got killed he's like why don't
we look more into the circumstances that
make these types of people that would do
something like this rather than you know
focusing on why you know us looking
different you know as a kind of a so
that's what he meant by saying it was
like victim blaming so initially because
there had been obviously so many
witnesses at the park that [ __ ] saw
this [ __ ] happen the police arrested
initially five people who had
participated in the attack but also kind
of kept the investigation open because
they suspected that there were between
15 and 20 other people who had either
witnessed the attack and didn't do
anything or had maybe participated in
the attack they weren't really sure so
in the end though they only had evidence
to prosecute five of the 5 initial
people that they had arrested this was a
15 year old and a 16 year old and also
they were like remanded in custody then
there was a two fifteen year olds and a
17 year old they got released on bail
now initially they were charged with
causing grievous bodily harm with intent
but then they decided like after Sophie
Lancaster died cuz like I said she
didn't die immediately she was in a coma
for a while and then she was brain dead
and her life support was turned off the
Crown Prosecution Service decided to
charge all five of the boys with murder
so they did try to like question other
people to try to like bring some other
people in and see if other people were
involved but they didn't have enough
evidence to do that so they just you
know assumed well these are the five
that main people that participate in the
attack and probably the other people
were just kind of like I said cuz it was
like a skate park it was kind of like a
popular hangout spot for like teenagers
that were like going there drinkin they
weren't really supposed to and [ __ ] like
that so they figured well maybe there
was just people that didn't have
anything to do with it
apparently and notably people that had
lived around this particular Park had
reported to the police prior that this
skate park was kind of a place for a
quote unquote drunken violet yobs
violent to yobs some british [ __ ] that
is yeah yobs or gal BOS yeah just means
like you know hooligans its hooligans
it's boy spelled backwards in case you
didn't know but yeah that's why so that
they'd been doing stuff like they were
in there drinkin and
you know reckon [ __ ] and whatever and
they had been reported like lots of
times but I guess the police didn't
really do anything about it
so the five suspects get charged with
murder now three got released on bail
two 15 year olds and a 17 year old now
initially all five of them pleaded not
guilty you know with the original things
but then they had like they had a
provisional trial they all pleaded not
guilty and then they had a regular trial
and then they all pleaded guilty to
grievous bodily harm with intent
although one of them Brian Herbert he
pleaded guilty to murder and then
another one Brendan Harris pleaded not
guilty to murder now the murder charges
against the other three got dropped
because I guess they didn't have as much
evidence for those and maybe they were
just kind of like you must minds or
whatever more observers yeah yeah so
that was that that was that kinda and
these were all miners too you have to
understand although like I said 15 16
and 17 that's all you can give a death
penalty in the US for that yeah in some
states you probably would and honestly
like um I what happened was because they
were all miners they didn't release
their names initially but then after the
after Brendan Harris was found guilty of
murder and I think Herbert Brian Herbert
was also found guilty of Arda they
decided to release their names because
they'd been they've been convicted so
the names were made public so they just
here's the thing it's like the guy this
one guy detective Superintendent McBride
well of the Lancashire Police said this
is one of the most violent murders he
had come across in his career he said I
do not think Herbert and Harris have
recognized how violent the attack was
they've just done it without thinking
but they seem to have enjoyed it and
carried on remorselessly kicking at two
very defenseless people who were unable
to protect themselves because of the
level of violence inflicted upon them
and then he said I'm very critical of
the parents involved like yeah I guess
so yeah hold on the parents just that
the boys need to die well no he said I
really don't think they've taken
completely seriously how repulsive this
incident was
the parents for the kids yeah well he
said that um when one of them Ryan
Harris I think was interviewed about the
crimes he said that his mom was there
and he was like laughing and joking
around with her so this cop was just
kind of like yeah this whole family is
[ __ ] they needed dad yeah it's like
yeah some people want to be like all
they want to pussyfoot around well you
can't use it death no yeah you can just
because they're people doesn't mean you
can't kill them they were killing people
I was a point-like I would act like this
yeah I mean that's not right that's not
right
kill him anyway you could argue that
they're teenagers like I said teens are
the worst they do stupid [ __ ] I didn't
say she was I didn't tell anybody I know
it's like in a way it's like it's hard
for me to relate because even when I was
15 or 16 years yeah I knew better I
wouldn't never do something like that
this is messed up [ __ ] a shoe and trash
and I ate a yeah and I feel like you
know yes they probably had horrible
upbringing clearly um but and there's a
point where there's gonna be people like
well you can't do that because that
makes you as bad as the offender I just
[ __ ] laughs no [ __ ] execute him
you're overthinking it but it's wrong so
what I mean what they did was right
there I mean okay I'm gonna say it's
like in general um you know I'm I'm kind
of like [ __ ] dad I well I think the
death penalty should be judiciously
applied because there's been a lot of
cases where you know someone murder
where someone was on yeah where where
someone was on death row and then it
found it they didn't do it like later on
in a DNA and [ __ ] like that so they need
to be really really careful with that
[ __ ] but in a case like this they know
they did it yeah there's not look I'm
not real sympathetic towards teenage
boys anyway I'm just saying and I have
two brothers but they're lovely people
so I and they would never have done
something like this even when they were
that age you got to stand back and look
at that [ __ ] from a [ __ ] higher
dimensions it's also a numbers game
yeah I'm telling about it's also a
numbers game yeah well yeah like I'm
saying it it's a moral gray area like I
said in this case um I don't know had I
been on the jury and these five boy had
had I seen these five boys knowing what
they had done and if they had been like
[ __ ] smug about it or thought it was
funny or something like that but like
yeah fry that mother because it's bad
enough like it's bad enough if you
[ __ ] kill somebody in a horrific way
like this no reason for it they were
just walking through like I said they
were just like walking to get [ __ ]
cigarettes and walking back to their
[ __ ] apartment there's with me is a
big difference between a cold-blooded
murder and a hot blooded [ __ ] type of
manslaughter well yeah those are two and
that's one the bomb brightly sees a
difference between those two things
because they are very different
not all homicides are equal they
definitely but they definitely look
enough and if you kill someone
methodically in the commission of a
robbery
it's equal you need to die you know what
I mean it's the same as a cold-blooded
murder and this I mean something like
this that just seemed like and I'm not
saying there's really any reason for
murdering people I'm just saying that
something like this where it was just
two innocent people who were just like
walking home because I guess this crime
pisses me off so much because I can
imagine because I've been in this
situation well think about this it's
like look you know look at me it's like
I don't look that weird right now but
it's like you know sometimes I'm
downtown and I'm like looking all Goths
out and [ __ ] I got my corset on I got
like tits oh yeah you gotta make and
[ __ ] like that and it's like and I'm
walking down the street in Orlando and I
think to myself what would happen if
like six dudes decided that they were
just gonna like kick my ass for no
reason it's like look because they don't
like how I look or they don't like that
I don't want to talk to them or
something like that so what would happen
in that situation is that she won't talk
to him that's usually what Hey Baby how
you doing that she has an answer and
then they there and then
get mad now look at we're talking about
don't think I'm a hey city get mad well
because in many cases I don't know like
I always feel like j-just tell them what
I do when they come up start rubbing on
you and dancing on you on the dance
floor what happens start trying to
butt-fuck them I do yeah I got this game
that I play and all the bouncers know
it's very affected all the I'll be up
there dancing weather and [ __ ] like that
and dude so try to get up on her like
that so I just [ __ ] get behind that
do it and I'll just be trying to get it
up here that stops and they'll turn
around they were like what what what and
I'll [ __ ] I'll plant a big-ass
[ __ ] kiss on a bitch's face yeah like
that and they don't know what to [ __ ]
do they don't know what to [ __ ] do
well yeah because they're not expecting
it if they're gonna be sexually
aggressive with her then I'm gonna be
sexually aggressive with that yes I'm
gonna be like alright okay how you land
which in a way that's good because then
every bouncer will be if you're watching
they're laughing and they just think
it's funny just doing this there's well
see the thing is that's the problem it's
that being uh being a woman kind of
sucks I have to say especially in
situations like that because you get
like dudes that [ __ ] with you it's like
you can get mad at them and tell you to
and tell them to [ __ ] off they won't do
it they don't take you seriously there's
like why are you being so mean why they
won't go away even though you're back on
the swashbucklin like [ __ ] yeah
Johnny Depp witnessing and then if I did
that then they'd be like alright yeah
I'm into this but if another dude does
it then they're like okay bye they don't
know what to [ __ ] do to do and they
just take right up so I'm gonna get some
of that boy [ __ ] that's just how it is
fair enough
it's [ __ ] it is very engineering
effective you're gonna get aggressive
with my woman I'm gonna get aggressive
with you I'm gonna get up so ladies get
your dudes to do that because it works
for you gotta be a man you got to be
very sick you gotta be buried also I
have to say to you that your friend
Shauna who has been on the show before
yeah I'm just ready to punch you yeah
yeah
channel just punching me if you come at
my woman then I'm gonna get right up on
you I'm gonna start trying to get my
nuts up in ya mm-hmm yeah and and dudes
are on Dave right it's very funny watch
the [ __ ] hilarious I'm like it's very
funny what I'm like what's the problem
you know you want to get open with
sexuality I'm gonna get open with
sexuality what it's very well gonna you
gonna you gonna get [ __ ] you know that
means it's gonna be prison style it's
gonna be like San Quentin well because
you're doing to them what were you and
they don't like it this is what kills me
it's like do you understand yeah I'd be
very don't hide your sexuality you got
to be very comfortable with your
masculinity and understand that there's
certain continent there's a woman and
then there's a whoa man that's when you
look at some man look at his booty you
go that looks like a woman's ass you
know talking about if you want to
[ __ ] get all up on my girl like that
they're not then yeah it's gonna be a
threesome yeah I mean I'm going first
you gonna eat I'm gonna get up in your
booty you know I'm in then they run I'm
gonna understand I don't want to I don't
understand it
that's what I mean I understand well
that's why it's effective it's because
they don't they don't seem to understand
that it is equal opportunity yeah it's
like women don't like that done to them
it's like so if another guy does it then
they get all like freaked out and
offended or like that motherly how I
feel I'll put my hand like that not be
like great and then they start running
away like where you going oh no like all
our friends are in the door because it
is always a soy boy it's always a sorry
boy
or joke yeah Jax understand it as soon
as I start doing it to him they're like
okay you got me I didn't know you with
her what is happening to you is that I
mean you know before
Korona came and like club and everything
I mean an independent bar we kind of
have a corner you know we're like we're
us and like all our friends were mostly
like the old crotchety guys
so we all kind of hang out in one area
and we're kind of like dancing stuff and
every now and then you get like some
idiots that don't like know you're not
sure what Dicky and they're not really
sure what's going on so they'll come
over there and start being like
obnoxious and girls and grabbing on
girls and whatever yeah and we will have
to correct them yes they say in the
shining it's gonna go it's gonna go
pirate on the high seas like I said we
because we've been going there for a
long time because we know everyone
almost watch them I'm gonna swashbuckle
the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] and then we
got it and depending on what year we're
talking about then it might have sucking
punk rockers up and they're like we'll
like my friend will or doctor Michael or
doctor Michael oh yeah you don't want to
get on the boat side of doctor dr.
Michael is a true bisexual you know I
mean I'm just [ __ ] with should we
even talk about doctor mom dr. Michaels
dr. Michael is a [ __ ] even doctor he's a
veterinarian
he's a veterinarian is a gothic goth to
the veterinary he's awesome got a bunch
of money and this [ __ ] strut
you look at him he just he just looks
like a pot-bellied really pot-bellied
little skinny dude with a potbelly like
skinny fat whether it's what he looks
like
but it looks like riff-raff from a
little bit from from yeah from [ __ ]
will it seemed that [ __ ] movie again
like a Rocky Horror looks like a real
friend and if you get sideways with that
[ __ ] you're gonna get you're
gonna get sexually assaulted homosexual
stuff he will do it for real
he's not joking all right I gotta keep
my nipples away from that [ __ ] remember
how that is he keeps her photo I'll be
like this he's like you're getting
bigger you're getting biggie getting big
stunts you [ __ ] doing man
he's hilarious he's [ __ ] hilarious
Annie also he's a big tequila drinker
also that's all
dancing crazy and [ __ ] and if you if
you're a [ __ ] mundane and you start
cone doing crazy [ __ ] around [ __ ]
goth [ __ ] women on the dance floor
that's it he's gonna be just on your
[ __ ] heels get on your [ __ ] booty
and he's like our age or older yeah he's
an old guy with long [ __ ] hair he's
[ __ ] kind of bald on the front of it
he looks like cross between [ __ ] riff
raff and Frankenstein
he's got it's like vampire a shirt on
yeah no it's not vampire it's Lily
monster oh that's right he's a vampire
one to that right a vampire he's got a
little Lily monster and [ __ ]
wearing [ __ ] shorts and fishnets yeah
oh man drinks like [ __ ] crazy and
he's strong as [ __ ] you look at him you
wouldn't think there's anything to me
could just [ __ ] pick you up yeah I
don't know if it's [ __ ] roid rage or
what I don't know what it is he he's
gotta [ __ ] access to all those
pharmaceuticals some weird [ __ ] happen
that could be he's got all kinds of
access know that's a weird veterinary
source drugs
I Love You dr. Michael I really did
Michael [ __ ] on that end of the bar I
met you know that's I I miss seeing
everybody that's what phantoms I miss
this pandemic [ __ ] I don't even know
what a [ __ ] foreigner would think of
Martin a [ __ ] doctor Michael if they
saw his ass first of all they wouldn't
know that he was a doctor you wouldn't
suspect that oh no you wouldn't suspect
the doctor he's a veterinarian doctor
well that's the funny thing that's the
thing that cracks me up about like
especially the goth scene in Orlando
which like you know was the one I'm most
familiar with is that a lot of the
people in there is like they look all
freaky and [ __ ] like that but they might
turn out they're [ __ ] lawyers and
doctors lawyers pharmacist yeah one of
them is a [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ]
gothic [ __ ] fetish couple that we
know that [ __ ] have a [ __ ] ton of
money and she is a district attorney and
he's an ex-convict
yeah that's always some weird [ __ ] there
so you would it's so interesting
that you can't again this is again
relating back to this case you can judge
a book by its cover
no like I feel like it's better nowadays
but back in the old days if you have
like tattoos or dreads or you know you
look like a goth or anything everyone
just assumed you were a bum nice people
got money but we know several several
people that are like [ __ ] freakazoid
looking and have like really like better
jobs than I ever she's a district
attorney he's an ex-convict she's
[ __ ] locking [ __ ] up and
they have female slaves mm-hmm it's a
whole thing there's a whole [ __ ]
thing but yeah in a mansion and like I
said a lot of the people if you just met
them in the bar you would you would
never know that there was like a doctor
or a lawyer or whatever but they are
they have all these [ __ ] bondage
slaves and [ __ ] living with them yeah so
weirdest [ __ ] thing because they
don't talked about I cooked pizza up in
that house we had a big party I'm
[ __ ] making pizza that [ __ ] was
because they had the best yeah it's been
a while since I've been dead a birthday
party for me one year but it's like that
was like four years ago yeah they used
to have the best parties but yes then I
wrap this case up though yeah cuz we
stopped I told him like when we took a
break I was kind of like it's one of
those kind of deals I tours you got
three cases that [ __ ] gonna take six
hours well yeah why is that because you
keep going off on it I'm trying to put
on a show
okay I'm trying to put on a chef try and
entertain where is this entertainment
material okay okay
but yeah so all these [ __ ] got
convicted happily so some of them not so
much because they were minors but you
know the main ones kind of got life
sentences or whatever yeah well the
judge said this was a terrible case
which is shocked and outraged all who
have heard about it at least wild
animals when they hunt in packs have a
legitimate reason for doing so right and
food you have none right and your
behavior on that night degrades humanity
itself
the judge said judge is correct he is
correct judge is correct so the only
thing I mean like I said you know I was
reading the interview with Robert Murphy
he sounds like a lovely lovely human
being
and it's kind of like a shame that he's
forever associated with you know now
he's just like oh I'm the guy whose
girlfriend got murdered and I got beaten
almost enough and he might never get
over that which kind of sucks so it
would be nice if he could just because
he said that in the interview was like I
wish I could just be known as like
Robert Mulvey the artist he's like you
know did illustration heart goes out to
the dude man he said like I said he
seems like a beautiful human being
and honestly he does not because I'm
gonna tell you right now he's a better
person than me because if that had
happened to me and I had survived and
those five young people and I used that
term loosely got out of prison I would
go and kill every single one of them
I'll go set those [ __ ] on fire
Mississippi Klan style out of [ __ ]
just like purification by fire that's
what I'm saying I will end the Klan well
just ring him up blow [ __ ] bars I'll
call in the Klan okay
okay I'm gonna do without the Koya yeah
I'm just not pleased my style yeah but
I'm just saying I was a cool touch
though was I yeah I thought it was me
right now in a clan [ __ ] burn those
boys man burn em up Barnabas well let
him do something productive there's some
product instead of visually yeah washing
their sheets but you know what I mean
clans gone now there's another era it
was just sounded cool imagine the Klan
coming [ __ ] burning a buck I would
rather honestly I would rather I don't
even to call nobody but I'm just saying
I'm just saying that like I admired this
dude for like being bigger than them and
he was just kind of like you know they
were it said they were victims too it's
like they were just kids it's like an
understanding you know they did stupid
[ __ ] it's like he was not saying you
like forgave him or anything but he's
like yeah I get it but um yeah I think I
would have probably just had it hunted
them down Canada Dexter style yeah and
eaten them but you know what I'm that's
just me I'm sure like I said I'm a
terrible person but um so he's a lot
better person than me but um so as I
said
the death of Sophie Lancaster really did
seem to kind of cause there was a like a
huge deal about I mean not only in the
goth community [ __ ] man they had like a
[ __ ] the Whitby goth weekend they had
like a whole thing I think they even
like dedicated a bench to her they're
like in Whitby so like if I could see it
like all the the Gotha
metal industrial festivals and [ __ ] like
that
did tributes to her I think like one of
the blood stock which is one of their
big like festivals over there they even
they still have a stage to this day as
far as I know them where they're trying
to like educate teenagers about like hey
maybe don't pick on people who look
different than you it's like that would
be nice if you could not do that but so
it really does seem like her death was a
catalyst for like a lot of like you know
better [ __ ] that came along I don't know
if it's any better nowadays cuz like I
said this was more than ten years ago I
think it is better I I think it's better
to eyes here yeah it's it you know and I
haven't been to the UK since 2009
probably but um you know it does seem
like people are more or less like shitty
toward people who are who look different
or that that era is gone I hope it is
because I mean I lived through it it
sucked I didn't you know and I got it a
lot better than a lot of people did but
we'll watch movies and I'll [ __ ] see
our fashion cues of what we used to wear
in mainstream movies now yeah yeah it's
not it's not the same like it was and
honestly whenever we were setting trends
back then we were [ __ ] breaking
ground and for a while like probably in
this is probably 2015 2015 when I had my
bright red hair and um you know even
when I was like at work and stuff and I
was dressed fairly normally because I
was at work but I still had bright red
hair um I would get comments but all the
comments were positive it wasn't um you
know it wasn't a thing where you were
getting like abused from people like
walking around like with the [ __ ] freak
it's not like it was so I do feel like
[ __ ] is going in like a better direction
even though it seems like it's not you
can go to any trailer park and find blue
hair and [ __ ] red hair [ __ ] now it
is it's really weird it's like not it's
not the same thing and honestly like
when I got my first tattoo yeah there's
like a big deal buried a girl's head and
even the tattoo artist said that to me
are you sure you want this on your arm
it's like everyone's gonna think you're
a [ __ ] it seems like yesterday it seems
like yesterday to us it does but to
younger people that was a long it was a
long time ago well yeah someone weren't
even born they weren't even born then so
it's just really fun in that word it's
really funny to think about that some
people we talked to it's like they
weren't even born like what I got my
first tattoo yeah I told you the other
day like we were at this was probably a
few months ago or a year ago last time a
story night was in town and I was
talking to Michael who's the singer
who's a really good friend of ours
yeah and he he is a sweetheart he's like
a really sweet guy yeah he's the
American version of [ __ ] Robert Smith
he is yeah he loves Robert Smith yeah
The Cure's his favorite yeah so I was
talking to him because they they had a
gig here in Orlando except from Miami
and they they came to I bar after and I
was talking to him by the bar and he
said something about him being born in
1990 and I said today I graduated from
high school in 1990 it's like I could I
was in basic your mom I was in basic
training in 99 it never occurred to me
sane that he was that young it was funny
is that like it's an American golf and I
think they're all Latino they're not
what are they I think they all are think
about it Ilya might be but I don't know
I think they all are I think he is too I
don't know nothing dear it's just funny
how I never asked him yeah because
remember they said it's so fun to hang
out the white people let's remember that
I was like I wasn't sure I wasn't sure
what they meant but yeah Miami well I
know how like what because
race and ethnicity is something the
United States that [ __ ] at least in
our scene we don't really even notice
that much well it's not really nice I've
never noticed it as it's just kind of
like it mattered as if you were gone or
not yeah it's like did you look cold did
you like it really thick all right this
is I don't give a [ __ ] what's so cool to
hand with all the white people and I was
like what I'm like Miami yeah and I was
like so and it's like I saw Latinas I
was like okay but then looking at them
and I go I think they're all I think
they're Latino but we never we never
think about it they are they are I don't
I don't know where Ilya is from but wait
if you look dude I don't I think they
are I never asked him I think they are
it doesn't matter
we don't worry if you guys are listening
tell me yeah I think they're all that
you know it's just something that never
occurred to me I was just like I like
you guys like cold they just thought was
funny that they were they thought it was
cool hanging out with white people when
I was like it is it is well it in a way
that's something that I always liked
about the Gaussian is like if you were
if you kind of looked Goffe and you were
like in music it's like no one gave a
[ __ ] about now you otherwise no they
didn't care what race you were they
didn't care what what sexuality or
gender you were they were just kind of
like whatever your goal
well actually like one of the [ __ ]
biggest mover and shakers in terms of
music as a black girl true Mouse hmm and
got this [ __ ] I mean she's just got this
[ __ ] everybody loves her she got a
husband I think though doesn't she she
does yeah yeah well yeah it's just it's
a it's just something that is not a big
deal like I said it's goth is something
that even though it's I feel like it's
probably perceived maybe particularly in
Europe is a right as a white thing and
maybe in the u.s. too but not over time
I I always kind of experienced it as not
really not really Rea specific not
really gender specific because even when
I was even in the 80s and 90s
I knew several people of many races I
to transgender people I knew you know
gay people straight people everything
like that there were into it and no one
really talked about it didn't matter
yeah it's like like I said it so
everyone kind of knew but it was just
kind of like yeah that was a race into
its own that's a good way of putting it
it was just kind of like that it's like
you know do you like the cool [ __ ] yeah
then we can hang out right which I think
that's a good way of looking at stuff
it's like if everybody's like into the
same [ __ ] then yeah you know that's just
how it goes all right so before the show
is like four hours long which it
probably will be anyway let's talk about
our last case which is the World's End
murder slash Angus Sinclair yeah this is
hold on one second what's up we get into
that I mentioned the mouse and I just
wanted to give her a plug obscura undead
obscure undead boys YouTube you'll see
what I'm talking about
and she does a lot of [ __ ] goth music
reviews but check out obscura undeads a
good show on YouTube also she is a
beautiful person
yeah she's awesome you'll love that
she's an awesome person yet she has been
over here a couple of times yeah she
burned her boyfriend she is a really
cool person yeah her husband actually
yeah yeah they got married but yeah so
uh this this got requested a couple of
times and this was something that I
wanted to you because that's a
documentary been a long time ago this is
a case where this is some [ __ ] that
happened like back in the 70s and they
didn't really have you know the forensic
you know technology like deal with it
and then they finally catch the
[ __ ] later on like in the 2000s
and then they find out he's like
responsible for all this other [ __ ] too
you know I mean it was kind of one of
those kind of deals so the World's End
murder took place in 1977 they called it
the World's End because the last place
that the two victims were seen alive was
a pub called the World's End in
Edinburgh Scotland now these two girls
whose names were christine Edie and
Helen
Scots they were both 17 years old hmm
and they had been out for you know night
out at the pub like you usually do now
evidently according to all witnesses
they had been there for a little while
Helen apparently was kind of tired she
wanted to go home sort of early but then
they had been seen with - at the time
unidentified men and apparently they had
been talking to these two men for 20-25
minutes and apparently one of them
offered them a ride home and they were
never seen alive again their bodies were
actually found the next day one of them
found completely naked one of them found
naked from the waist down they had been
raped and strangled mmm so for many
years they did not know who had done
this [ __ ] but then later on they
actually caught the dude that did it was
actually two dudes which they knew at
the time but they didn't you know know
who it was but they later find out found
out that it was this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
named Angus Sinclair who thankfully died
early last year in prison but it took
him a really long time to get caught
which is kind of sad so this dude he's
one of those dudes that started real
early and it seems like one of those
cases where if only somebody would have
just locked this [ __ ] up or hit
him in the head with a brick or
something like that like a lot of
people's lives would be saved because
even from the time that he was a
teenager he was psychologically assessed
and psychologists were saying look this
dude is a sexual predator and we don't
think he's going to get any better and
this was when he was like 16 17 years
old and we do not advise that he ever be
let out again because they knew they
they could see it and this was like back
in the 70s so back in the 60s even back
when they weren't as sensitive to that
right it's like they're like look we
don't think this do
needs to be running around like in
public because we don't think that he's
ever gonna get any better and it's like
he's just gonna be a danger his whole
entire life to women and children as it
turned out but for whatever reason that
just seemed to be not heeded and many
women died as a result
damn so Wow so his first offense like I
said and when the World's End murders
occurred in 1977 you have to imagine
that this murder and there was a series
of murders in Glasgow as well which were
initially not were not connected to the
World's End murder but later we found
out were perpetrated by the same person
or persons but at the time they didn't
know who did it but later on when they
caught him through DNA and [ __ ] like
that and then they went back and like
looked into his history or whatever they
found out that this dude started
offending very early like so his first
[ __ ] was like in 1959 when he was 13
years old burglary breaking and entering
that kind of [ __ ] that was from 1959
1961 when he was 15 years old already he
started already lewd and libidinous
practices on an 8 year old girl 8 yes
when he was 15 he got three years
probation for that because he was still
a kid the same year 1961 he was actually
convicted of killing a seven-year-old
girl raping and killing a seven-year-old
girl Katherine regal he got sentenced to
10 years in prison although he only
served six years keep in mind he was
still a minor okay yeah that's a [ __ ]
bad warning sign there which like I said
and it was around this time period that
psychologists assessed him we were like
yeah don't let this do that yeah because
no even though it was a kid they could
see it well because one of the things
that they noted was that he seemed to
have zero empathy and he seemed obsessed
with sex hmm it in a like to a degree
which was like remarkable in the sense
that's been something more organically
wrong with this [ __ ] he must
have uh yang and honestly if you've seen
like later because like I said he did a
lot of [ __ ] before they caught him or at
least caught him for all the murders and
[ __ ] and he was one of those dudes that
just seemed to have no um no feeling
whatever like when they were questioning
him about [ __ ] even when he was a kid
they're like he would just sit there and
just not answer and he would just like
stare at you like he didn't give a [ __ ]
hmm you could just like question him he
gets like like sales say you could come
at him this way come at him that way and
show like that and he would just sit
there and stares like he didn't like
give a single show that's some kind of
organic brain damage there definitely
seem to be something wrong with them and
honestly um I was watching a documentary
about him earlier and uh he had a
brother and the brother was talking
about when he got convicted of the first
murder when he was 16 years old
the girl was seven and the brother was
trying to get him to confess to police
cuz the brother knew he had done it you
know but he's like he's like he was so
[ __ ] cold and like calculating like
the first murder he kills the 7 year old
girl right he rapes and murders a seven
year old girl like somebody comes to the
door like in the middle of it and he
just goes to the door and be like oh
whatever it's like I can't come to
whatever right now and he just like what
and he's like totally calm boys even
worried about he even called the cops
and said Oh a little girl fell down the
stairs
hmm and he was just like totally chill
yeah and like the brother was just kind
of like you know you have to confess and
all this other kind of [ __ ] I'm the
brother and he finally did well I think
he suspected because he like knew that
his brother
[ __ ] up and he's like after that
happened he's like with his brother he's
like yeah I'm done with that right yeah
and later on when he was the old man cuz
I saw an interview with him his old man
he's like I wish that I had killed him
when he was a kid right yeah he said
well I wish I had killed to prevent evil
right which yeah I could kind of get
that to like earlier on in the show you
said there's no reason for murder like I
would never accept murders yeah there is
there's a lot of good reasons for
murders and this [ __ ] is a good
example I would have killed that kid
[ __ ] to prevent [ __ ] the depth of
[ __ ] innocent people yesterday night
and it's like it's it's so it's so hard
because it's like you know it's a kid
and it's like you know they might grow
out of it it's like I don't know but
sometimes and we talked about like a lot
of serial killers and [ __ ] like that on
the show where even when they were a kid
and in this case particularly it does
seem like even as a kid he seemed like a
complete remember that so see about that
time we were in the car and you asked
him about that girl who [ __ ] cut deck
little kids dick off and [ __ ] killed
him and [ __ ] remember that yes yeah I
would do what I say I don't remember
which is that I said I killed that
little girls lungs nobody knew about it
yeah well there's some people that just
got to go their company there's a dip a
go-between well there's a difference
between kids who do [ __ ] without really
thinking about it in who are just cuz
they're dumbass kids cuz get dumb that
little girl was thinking about that
that's what I mean and there's a
difference and it definitely seems like
Angus Sinclair was a type of dude where
his brother who I think was only a
couple years older than him he saw it he
was like that he's not right yeah just
because they're people doesn't mean you
can't do what it is that has to be done
well the [ __ ] are evil some [ __ ]
some some people not normal yeah some
people gotta go some people are just
[ __ ] man it's I think it's rare but as
I said we talked about a lot of serial
killers on this show and a lot of them
are
made like through there's like
circumstances or whatever but I do feel
like there are a few that yeah that from
a very early age you can tell that
there's something the matter with that
get the [ __ ] human mind is a very
complicated thing everything has to go
right for this [ __ ] to go right if
something goes wrong in it you might
have some very bad outcomes you know and
sometimes sometimes society isn't
equipped to deal with a situation like
that yeah you have sometimes them
sometimes sometimes a [ __ ] person has
to deal with [ __ ] on their own you know
yeah but it just depends on the
situation
you know [ __ ] society isn't
well-equipped to deal with everything
there are some things that just have to
be dealt with by [ __ ] people well and
things like this are thankfully quite
rare yeah yes rare yeah I don't think it
turns up because as I said it has to be
a perfect storm of some horrible genetic
[ __ ] and then maybe you get like dealt
a bad hand and your family thing and
it's like this and all these government
officials and lawyers jump in and this
and that and psychologists and then they
try to talk it all out it becomes a big
[ __ ] all I'm trying to make money
off of it when really the kid just needs
to be thrown in and down water with a
damn brick or on its leg you know it's
like accidentally not yeah alligator
yeah run that [ __ ] over you know some
[ __ ] like that
yeah but run that [ __ ] over yeah but
yeah I'm just well there's a reason why
there's a whole sub-genre of horror
that's like killer kids yeah
because it's a fear that people have
because what would you do I've thought
about this too because I've watched a
couple movies this is kind of like a
horrifying concept to me what would you
do if you had a kid and that kid you
knew was [ __ ] evil what would you do
could you kill it what is a person what
is consciousness how does it why is a
person conscious and is
kid like this are they a conscious
person is there something wrong with
them that prevents consciousness from
happening that's what I mean there was
there you don't I mean it's all gonna be
a matter of degree because you know what
I mean it's everything's on a continuum
it's like I know that the like the laws
have to be like you have to have like a
stopping place somewhere you have to
have like a lineage understand law and
the limitations of law each country has
its own set of laws it's based upon the
mores of the people of that country can
you trust that I'm gonna say no you
can't trust that all the time there's
always a margin of error you know well
you know the laws in Saudi Arabia are
not the same as the laws of the United
States it's different kind of people's
different opinions laws opinion right
and wrong as opinion you know a lot of
it based upon religions and sometimes
religions that only used to be believed
in ya know by the society I'm skeptical
of the law I just am sorry well the
thing about law is that it's only as
good as the people making the laws and
everyone is imperfect and as I said you
know reality is messy um there aren't
any hard limits between and this is a
good case of that because you know you
can argue it's very easy to argue that
you know you have somebody that was a
serial killer later on and like you look
back at their life like after they've
killed however many people they've
killed you look back at their childhood
and they're like okay wall you could
tell there was something the matter with
them like it started early they were
torturing animals or whatever it was
that we're doing so it's easy to say in
hindsight oh that person was going to be
a serial killer but the problem arises
because you don't know because there's
other people there's other kids that do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like that and they turn
out okay so it's kind of like there's
nowhere there's no clear way to
draw a line in that situation you know
what I'm saying that's what makes it
difficult is because there aren't any
clear lines of [ __ ] although I should
say that an Angus Sinclair's case he
certainly seemed like a piece of [ __ ]
from a very early age yeah and probably
should have been smothered yeah is it
I'm just saying it's not only that there
was not and like I said it's not only
like torturing animals which is bad
enough I mean like I I think you should
be just killed just for that yeah cuz
for [ __ ] sake stop it but I mean when
you're 13 years old and you're already
like doing robberies and then your
honors 1516 you're already like raping
and you know assaulting like [ __ ]
kids like younger than babe yeah I'm not
I'm not sure that you're going to get
any better I'm just not sure about that
I mean I gotta go you gotta go
I can remember being a young kid like a
preteen and a teenager
yeah and as stupid as I was I got asked
to I wouldn't have done yeah I'm not a
boy so it's a different man look I'm
telling you boys my boys aren't don't do
that that's what I mean it's like most
people don't do that thankfully ya know
when I was a when I was a boy that age I
was [ __ ] like nice and like
considerate and you know I mean what
happened what's that I was still trying
to get into [ __ ] but you know I'm
saying I was gonna talk my way into it's
gonna just be pretty and we get into it
I'm not gonna be like how much he was
getting to be a nice person I was nice I
was just wanted so yeah I'd go bath
chauffeur I got photos they got pictures
to prove it you know I'm talking about
you guys I'm just gonna [ __ ] be cute
and get it yeah but you know I know I'm
just saying you know do what this dude
is doing yeah normal just seventeen
doing that sixteen sixteen doing that
when I was sixteen if I saw him doing
that it killed him back now six thousand
I mean it's like how the [ __ ] Christ
his head it's [ __ ] stupid and
[ __ ] is like 15 year old boys I know
this dude I'm not normal then he like
raping and murdering a seven-year-old
now I'm telling you that's messed up I
mean I think I should have she's guys
she's trying to tell how these boys are
so bad boys are actually good they would
do they would they would would have
stopped that most of them like what are
you doing of course of course of course
they were talking about I don't know of
course they would have of course it
would have yeah you know they're like
wrong that's not normal behavior
yeah it's not normal well and obviously
even back in the 60s you know even back
in the 60s a [ __ ] psychologist who
studied him when he was like just a
teenager was like yeah I don't think you
should ever let this kid back out on the
streets because he's never gonna get any
better
and sadly no one really took heed of
that advice yeah you know I mean so yeah
in 1961 he gets 10 years for killing
Katherine real who was a neighbor of his
she was 7 years old
raped and murdered her uh he got a
10-year sentence he was a minor however
he only served six years so he gets out
in 1970 he actually marries a nurse
named Sarah Hamilton and also ended up
having a son he had done like some kind
of like I guess job training and [ __ ]
like that in prison so when he got out
he was able to get a job as like a
painter and like a decorator and [ __ ]
like that
I can only like you need an education
for that well you know like he'd he had
like a trade or what yeah however seven
years later in 1977 it is believed that
he murdered six women within seven
months although they did not know that
he did that until many many many years
later um he's good that one a month yeah
basically so the women he killed would
be Frances Barker it was the
seven Hilda McCauley who was 36 Agnes
Cooney who was 23 and Anna Kenny who was
20 these women were all from Glasgow and
he was also responsible for the infamous
World's End murders in Edinburgh which
took place in 1977 that was christine
Edie and Helen Scott now later on he
also was thought to have murdered
another woman in 1978 17 year-old Mary
Gallagher also Glasgow all right so what
was that okay so we're talking about
what are you doing I'm gonna show you
that [ __ ] memory we were talking
about Mouse yes mouse is on alive she's
streaming writing that live great I told
her that was Nats Mouse she's a good mom
that's her Sakura on death she's like
she's cool she's that that was so
[ __ ] cool yes Friday night pandemics
on so she's gonna go ahead and spin cuz
no one can go out to the know I can go
out which sucks yeah but yeah also I
should say we had a pause because you
had you had to go to the bathroom you
know look at Pookie she's looking at me
so who key was in the backyard yeah near
the [ __ ] Lake
wagon a beer let's see it and there was
a deer she was hanging out with the deer
oh [ __ ] she's like oh [ __ ] I don't care
she was alarmed
she's look at the [ __ ] spill on the
floor going oh [ __ ] what did you do yeah
I'm always what I've always thought that
was gonna happen because that table is
not super stay yeah well I pulled her up
she was holding on the carpet in the car
yeah well yeah she was on the earth she
was hanging out with deer you guys hang
out with a deer you
yeah so yeah let's talk a little bit
about the worlds and murders because
that was kind of like the thing that
brought this [ __ ] like name
into the spotlight so this happened in
1977 was two seventeen year old girls
Christine Edie and Helen Scott and they
founded a pub and as I said earlier they
were just kind of hanging out with a
couple of other of their friends and
apparently they had been seen talking to
two men earlier in the evening who were
not identified until much later
um evidently what happened was it wasn't
super late but I guess they had gone out
in the parking lot one of them was a
little bit of knee braided because one
police officer did report that they had
that she had kind of stumbled and he had
been passing by and he'd helped her get
back on her feet or whatever but done
like after that apparently these two
guys were like hey we'll give you a ride
home or we'll take you where you need to
go I think was the quote that they said
and we all know how that turned out so
the two girls both disappeared that
night after 10:00 or 11:00 p.m. in
Edinburgh the next day
Christine Edie was found out in the
field she was lying on her back
completely naked her wrists were bound
with one leg of her tights the other leg
of the tights had been used to strangle
her her underwear had been stuffed into
her mouth and her bra was around her
head like holding the underwear in place
she had been beaten severely bitten
several times and braved Helen Scott her
friend was found a couple miles away
also in a field in a different field she
was found facedown she still had her
coat and top on but she was naked from
the waist down
her coat belt was binding her hands and
Christine's belt was around her neck she
had been strangled with it there was
also a boot print on the side of
her head you know so apparently she had
been stomped in the head she had also
been raped and had probably had to watch
her friend be raped and murdered before
she herself was killed now you have to
imagine that in 1977 this was an bura
and this was a fairly safe City at the
time from my understanding Glasgow has
always been more of more known for more
for having like a higher crime rate I
guess but in the 70s like Edinburgh was
pretty safe so this was like a pretty
big [ __ ] deal when this happened in
the 70s which is probably why this got
more attention than the other murders
that had happened in Glasgow that would
later be related to this same murderer
so one thing even though obviously they
didn't have DNA they didn't have any of
that [ __ ] in the 1970s but the Scottish
police at the time in Enberg did have
the presence of mind to think hey maybe
we should save all of this stuff because
maybe someday someone will be able to
you know figure this crime out because
you know they'll be better forensic
evidence so they did at least have the
presence of mind to do that so they did
like keep everything in very good like
condition and store everything for
future investigators so now the thing
about it even though they didn't connect
these crimes at the time a little while
after the World's End murders occurred
and as I said reason they're called
World's End is because that's what the
pub was called and as far as I can
determine that pub still exists and it's
still called the World's End and sadly
it's famous for this but a little while
after that happened a girl named Mary
Gallacher who was 1617 rather she was
abducted in Glasgow and raped and
murdered now she had also been strangled
in a very similar manner one thing one
kind of signature of Angus Inc
Claire and his accomplice was that they
would use the victims own clothing to
strangle them with usually underwear or
stockings or tights or something like
now how old was he when he was doing
this do you man um he was probably much
I mean this was late 70s in his 20s he
probably wasn't a thirties because what
he didn't get caught until 2005 in the
2000s and then you know he died in
prison just recently he died in 2019 I
believe and he was 73 so he got away
with it for a very long time only
because a lot of crimes had happen in
Glasgow and the world then murder having
Umbra witch it's only about 50 miles
apart but in the 70s they wouldn't have
connected those two crimes it didn't
really happen until later on until they
actually figured hey maybe we should
like do a kind of like larger analysis
of this and they kind of like did a
breakdown of all the unsolved murders in
Scotland which was about a thousand I
think over whatever time period and
they're like there were only this many
that had this particular signature which
was women that were taken from clubs
they were raped they were strangled with
items that their own clothing so in
those particular cases the mo was like
so singular that they knew that they
were probably committed by the same
person now I should note that very early
on in the investigation Scottish
authorities were fairly sure that the
world end murder was committed by at
least two people not only because there
were two victims involved that were
found dead several miles apart you know
and obviously it would have been easier
for two individuals to have corralled
these two
victims into doing what they were or
they were doing but also because the two
women had been found with different
knots in there ligatures which one of
the knots seemed like a more
professional kind of like you know I'm a
sailor kind of like her I know a lot
about knots kind of thing and the other
one was kind of like I'm just a basic
[ __ ] you know I mean in regards to
knots
so from very early on they were pretty
aware that this was probably two
perpetrators um later on they would
prove to be correct about that however
by the time they had enough evidence to
figure that out one of the perpetrators
was dead hmm so you know that's how that
goes so you know as I said there had
been a lot of murders in Glasgow that
had been this same MO but they didn't
immediately link them with the N burn
murders because like I said this was the
1970s they didn't know anything about
DNA then know anything about that now
the weird thing about it is one of the
murders that had taken place in Glasgow
one of the victims in a Kenny um the
last person to see her alive who was a
woman named Wilma Sutherland was the
same woman who was married to a dude
named Gordon Hamilton who was the second
perpetrator who was Angus Sinclair's
second dude they were apparently the two
of them
Angus Sinclair this was his
brother-in-law and they were going out
raping and murdering women because
that's what you do yeah yeah with your
brother-in-law of course yeah even got
to make it a family thing miss quad -
yeah like I didn't kill a [ __ ] yeah I
mean I guess Englert addition did some
[ __ ] on his own but he did those two
they're pretty sure they have DNA
evidence to prove that both of the deeds
were there um that they did this [ __ ]
together some crazy [ __ ] man
I tell you yeah what the hell is will
here be more or less was this again this
is 87 70s later this was 77 78 yeah so
Gordon Hamilton actually ended up
becoming a drunk and he died in a
homeless shelter in Glasgow in 1996 so
he never actually got charged with any
of this [ __ ] luckily for him I guess um
because like I said Angus Sinclair had
been in and out of jail since he was
like a [ __ ] teenager but he didn't
get it didn't get realized that he was a
[ __ ] serial killer until much later
on which is it's one of those things
well like I said this was the kind of
thing where even when he was a teenager
psychologists saying don't let some
[ __ ] out because yeah it bad
things will happen and they were correct
and it seemed like nobody heeded that I
know it's like easy to say in hindsight
because we know what he did but he it
seems like some people dropped the ball
on this [ __ ] do you
so yeah as I said like about a year
after the very famous World's End murder
murder in Edinburgh a 17 year old
married Gallacher who was abducted in
Glasgow raped and murdered she also had
the same kind of thing where she'd been
strangled with like items her own
clothing she actually her throat slashed
she wasn't strangled now somebody saw
him though in this particular murder and
an identikit as they used to call it
back then you know composite sketch was
drawn of him now it seems like because
his face because the composite sketch
looked a lot like him I have to say it
was a good one I've seen the eye the
identikit sketch and I've seen sketch
and I've seen like the photo of his real
face so it does seem like the
description of him was pretty accurate
so I guess it got like around in the
media
and he got like scared about it so he
decided that instead of going after 17
18 year-old women he was gonna go after
some little kids instead damn because it
does seem like after that because like
these two girls they were 17 they were
murdered in 1977 and then he murdered
another one in 1978 and then between
1978 and 82 it seemed like he went more
into like rape of like children trying
to wrap in a glass show trying to be
more outraged either that or because he
was like well I might get caught doing
that [ __ ] so I'm better I better like
target some little children so maybe he
thought you'd get away with that easier
I don't know I thought maybe he'd get
away with it or I don't know it's like
some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] so nobody knows
the creepy thing is like nobody knows
exactly how many people how many
children he assaulted at this time now I
saw a documentary about him there's a
couple ones like the BBC did one and
there was like one that was like
Scottish specific with all the accents
and everything I I'm sorry I had to turn
the [ __ ] closed captioning on I
understood most of what they were saying
but 7/7 was like I lived over there for
a while so I know I know the accents and
stuff but even the Scottish accent I'm
just kind of like like what the [ __ ]
they say wait what yeah and I bet I had
to back it up her ex-husband was [ __ ]
Scottish and I yes well she's okay
that's totally different totally
different this old I met the
[ __ ] at a club one time and I
was talking to him I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this dude saying and the
weirdest why we're still married that
was like what well the weird thing
understand his accent to me because I
met him in the United States he came
here to meet me and I never had trouble
understanding what he was saying now
when I went to Wales I didn't have
trouble understanding what they were
saying but their accents in Wales were
much thicker than his I thought yeah so
I mean his
because he was like really into like
American action movies and all this kind
of stuff so his accent was not super
super thick
I didn't think other members of my
family would always say to me it's like
what is he saying like he was like
talking some alien language I'm like
it's English yeah but no I mean yeah so
from an American point of view it sounds
medieval I did not I did not find him
hard to understand at all
however like his family but like when I
went over there and like some of his
family members I did a couple of them I
did find a few things hard to understand
but not all that much but even the Welsh
will tell you and the Welsh are kind of
like they kind of get [ __ ] on a lot by
the English
they're called sheep shaggers that call
those of the co show all those guys this
the Scottish get kind of yeah
although I will say uh you know i-i've
been all over Wales and somewhat it is a
beautiful beautiful you never saw any
sheeps getting shagged did you I did not
okay I saw lots of sheep I didn't see
anybody shagging though I have to tell
you not like they would do that just in
the open but I'm just saying I never had
any trouble understanding him at all I I
didn't think he had a very thick accent
but when I went over there some of the
accents of his relatives were a little
thick but I didn't really under that
much trouble understanding them Scottish
accents even Welsh people will tell you
we have no [ __ ] idea what the Scots
are saying and a lot of English people
will say that as well I can understand
about 75% of what they're saying but
some of the [ __ ] I was just so I had to
turn the I had to shown that closed
captioning on I have to say and the
closed captioning was like that you know
how YouTube does like the [ __ ]
automatic it was it was terrible I was
like well some of this stuff did the
like the thing I was like that's not
what they said but whatever so I don't
know what what the [ __ ] I went off on
that but yeah so Sinclair gets out he
like [ __ ] does the shoot with the
kids between
seventy-eight 92 there's like all these
[ __ ] rapes I don't I don't know about
like killing them but he does like all
this sexual assault on kids in Glasgow
around this time period and they are not
entirely sure how many kids that he did
it to um this one documentary that I saw
which was like I said kind of more
Scottish specific they had they
interviewed a couple of his victims that
had survived and they were you know they
were like in shadow and stuff because
they didn't want to like be public but
they were talking about I mean they were
just little at the time and they were
talking about he was just like a dude
that was like in the neighborhood and he
would do [ __ ] like oh hey can you like
take some this message to your mom or
like tikva he was one of those kind of
[ __ ] where he was like he had
like a ruse right and he's like can you
tell your mom like give her your mom
this money or I'm gonna like you run an
errand for me or some [ __ ] like that
right and the little kids were like then
like seven eight-year-old girls and
they'd be like okay whatever and they
would like go up and do and then he
would come back and like do [ __ ] to them
and they would like yeah yeah this [ __ ]
needs to be killed well he's dead now
yeah it's fine Becca had smack the [ __ ]
out of that [ __ ] but yeah
so he gets caught for this [ __ ] in 1982
now in 1992 he pleaded guilty to 11
charges of rape and indecent assault
against minors and at this point this is
1980 remember he admits to authorities
that he's like well it could have been
hundreds of people I don't know if
that's true or not it might be because
this seems like that kind of
[ __ ] but he got sentenced to
life in 1982 now he's still in prison
20 years later he's getting ready to go
before the parole board and then it
comes to light that he might have
something to do with that long ago 1978
murder of Mary
liquor so like I said this is not he
doesn't get accused of even though he's
most famously you have the World's End
murder killer that wasn't the one that
actually brought him to the attention
like he was in prison for other [ __ ] for
like raping little children um so he was
already in prison he's at PETA
yeah um although initially he had
started out raping and murdering 17 18
19 year olds and then it seems like he
was so difficult he had to fly again
that's what I mean it's like he went
like for easier prey it seemed like
because it seemed like he knew that
authorities were on his tail so it's
like oh I well maybe I'll go here like
right I feel like it's less heat on me
or some [ __ ] like that it really does
seem like that well what it is the
victim cannot [ __ ] actually be able
to communicate as well to the police
about what happened
yeah probably he's talking about well
yeah that's what semester I was like
well if I rape these little girls they
won't be able to tell the cops they
won't give a cop's a good [ __ ] report
so I'll get away yeah because it's a kid
they wouldn't remember I feel like
that's kind of like the justification of
the F files everywhere yeah this [ __ ]
needs to be raped
hopefully I jump on that [ __ ] a
swashbuckler Jeannette put the cameras
on me like okay you're [ __ ] that
we'll have what we'll have like [ __ ]
light shining and disco balls and [ __ ]
we'll make an event out of it I'll make
this [ __ ] pay-per-view imagine the
amount of money we would make probably
you would make a lot of money he had to
load me up with a bunch of viagra like
doing viagra and rad 114 [ __ ] like dead
[ __ ] testosterone testosterone what
dude that they'd be like undoubted yeah
like a pedophile
yeah raping these little girls he's like
he's gonna get raped and you just like
it would be like had a paper like a huge
pay-per-view of somebody just like yeah
you [ __ ] trucks and shorts don't know
where so he could see what it was like
that'd be hilarious
honestly I'm just making [ __ ] up but I'm
saying they'd be hilarious yeah you know
would be so like I said so even though
the World's End murder is the one that
he's like most famous for that was
actually not the one that first brought
him to the attention is like being a
murderer it was actually the case of
Mary Gallagher which was a year later in
1978 they found out that because they
had preserved a lot of the DNA evidence
like clothing and whatever from the
1970s because in the future they'll have
like better DNA technology or better
forensic technology so we'll save all
this [ __ ] so they did so they found out
later on like 20 years after the [ __ ]
crime was committed that you know
[ __ ] Angus and Claire was coming up
for parole and they're like look your
DNA was found at the scene of the Mary
Gallagher murder they found his DNA on
the victim
so they actually decided they were gonna
bring him to trial for that particular
in for other charges now at this stage -
they also found the DNA and this was
also found in the World's End murder
case of his [ __ ] brother-in-law
Gordon Hamilton but by the time that
this happened
Gordon Hamilton was sadly already dead
he had died in 1996 in a homeless
shelter so he couldn't be prosecuted
obviously so they the Scottish police
launched something called Operation
Trinity because they believed that Angus
Sinclair is probably responsible for a
lot more rapes and murders than what is
in what is initially believed so they
review every murder that took place in
Scotland since 1968 which as I said
earlier was more than a thousand murders
and found that six bore a very specific
signature which they believed you know
made the murders all connected so they
tested all of those inputs
ocular and all of these murders had
happened within a period of seven months
why are you looking at me like that
waiting why am I looking at you you're
looking at me like no listen to the show
okay look like you're looking at me like
what are you talking about now I know
I'm into it okay yeah so at this point
um they feel like well we have a
signature here we know that it's
probably Angus and Claire they want to
do this [ __ ] with Gordon Hamilton but
he's already dead so they can't like
[ __ ] do anything about that
so they contact the FBI because at this
point you know this is fairly early on
in the whole serial killer thing kind of
and they're like the FBI in Quantico
were kind of like at the cutting edge of
this so like we need your help in this
situation or we need another set of eyes
on this so they get an FBI agent named
mark safarik I guess is how you
pronounce his name in Quantico and he
looks into the case as well and he
looked into these particular six murders
that they believed to be from the same
perpetrator so he says we look into
these cases to see whether they're
linked and he says yes they were
probably committed by the same offender
so the Scottish police then plan to
charge Sinclair with all six of the
murders however there were a couple of
problems going into the trial so the
police in the jurisdiction were one of
the murders had taken place had lost
some of the evidence also another one of
the murders that they had attributed to
Angus and Claire later on the murder of
Francis Barker had actually been
[Music]
attributed to another person and he had
been in prison for many years at this
point
oh she is they got that one wrong yeah
yeah and the sad thing about this is
that he actually died in prison yeah and
DNA and evidence later showed that
he didn't do it damn was he guilty of
any other crimes um I don't know about
that but he didn't he wasn't guilty the
crime he was putting the [ __ ] jail
for damn he wasn't guilty that murderer
cuz Angus Sinclair did it man
can you imagine a lot of times a guy
will [ __ ] get locked up for something
that he didn't do but he did some other
[ __ ] yeah like he feel less bad and that
is like well he wasn't convicted of the
[ __ ] that they said that he did but at
least he do the other [ __ ] I don't know
about this okay a lot of times the
prosecutor will say I I kind of suspect
this guy didn't do this one but I know
he did that one that's a lot of times
what happened well there's the thing to
wear and I can understand like this is
understandable because if you know that
the dude did this [ __ ]
but you can't prove it but you know that
he did this [ __ ] and you can prevent
yeah then do that then like he'll be in
jail at least in case he did that [ __ ]
roach is worse and then at least he's
off the streets right so I can see why
you would a lot of times they do that
the prosecutors do that a lot of times
which yeah you I mean the way our legal
system is set up you can see why they do
that because it's like look it's like
this is a lesser charge but at least
he's off the street right you know yeah
and you didn't get convicted for this
horrible like torture murder over here
but at least we could convict him first
and over here aggravated battery or
whatever the [ __ ] this [ __ ] ever and
well at least we'll keep him off the
street for however many years this
sentences I mean it's better than
nothing because the thing is it's like
if you just tried to try them for that
[ __ ] for the worst crime that's like
a higher you know standard right think
you have to keep - and if he gets off on
that they'll just like let his ass loose
and then he might go kill somebody else
so you know what I mean so I can see why
they do that like for a lesser charge so
the thing about this and I have to tell
you because the dude that got convicted
for Francis Barker's murder was named
Thomas Ross what young Oh
[ __ ] it was you know but middle name was
Ross
yeah well Thomas Ross young that's what
yeah last name was young so I don't know
if it was Ross young like that was a
hyphenated earth that was just like his
last name though that's I think that's
not my name that's that's not my name my
middle name is not Ross but yeah this it
it's not I know what your middle name is
yeah are you saying don't tell anybody
for me I'm not gonna tell you what I'm
like inside buddy was this I know you're
embarrassed but I know what it is do you
know I don't want anybody dachshund me
do you know my middle name is um you
don't I forgot Jimmy something rather
Ashford
well my maiden name was Mitchell
Mitchell that's right but my middle name
my middle name is yeah do you know no
hope
yeah that's right you told me you told
me a long time ago yes no funny I'll
live with her I don't know her middle
name you don't know a lot of [ __ ] about
me oh listen you don't know my birthday
is you didn't know what my middle name
oh thanks look at her I was tailing yeah
I got a head injury I can't remember
that kind of [ __ ] you probably told me
you know like I'm like what I don't
remember my own [ __ ] that's true yeah I
have an excuse
yeah so they decide in 2007 um so they
decide they have some evidence of some
of the murder cases there so we're gonna
go all out on the [ __ ] Angus Sinclair
thing because like I said Gordon
Hamilton was dead by this time so it's
like we're gonna try and like convict
him all the [ __ ] that was in 2007
now the problem arose because okay they
found DNA on the bodies of the worlds
and murders victims Christine Edie and
Helen Scott however for whatever reason
um it wasn't introduced at the trial
that the DNA
was actually found it wasn't only found
like on one of the victims coats but it
was also found like in the knots of the
ligatures which would suggest that this
was a forceful you know you were
forcefully like restraining these girls
or whatever it wasn't like a consensual
encounter so because they didn't
introduce that evidence in the trial
Angus Sinclair was successfully able to
argue that the sex was consensual and
that the murderer was perpetrated by
Gordon Hamilton the brother-in-law who
was already dead at this point
hmm so because Angus made that argument
or because his defense attorneys made
that argument they were able to
introduce enough reasonable doubt that
he got off with the [ __ ] hmm now he was
already in prison for other [ __ ] so he
wasn't like he was like walking for a
year and right then however so many
people were pissed off by this outcome
and because in Scotland at the time
there was a thing and we have this too
in the US where you had the double
jeopardy thing you can't be like
prosecuted twice for the same crime
however I think in the u.s. I'm not
really sure when the u.s. kind of like
made it more less lenient or more
whatever it was but it's like it's kind
of like you can be tried because you can
be retried in the u.s. if they find new
evidence that says oh yeah they can
really hit that [ __ ] okay
well in Scotland you couldn't do that
like if you've been tried once for that
charge you couldn't be tried for that
charge again American law is based on
English common law it is very similar
rights very similar so Scotland it had
this law where if you had been tried and
since Angus and Claire had already been
tried for this particular murder you
know double jeopardy law said that he
couldn't be retried for that again
however the fact that the [ __ ] came out
later about his DNA being found in in
side the knots of the ligatures which
would suggest that he had been there
he'd been participated it was like not
consensual blah blah blah so the whole
entire law was changed and honestly this
was the first case in Scottish law where
a person was tried again for the same
exact charge because new evidence had
come and this was the case that like
changed the law in Scotland so they kind
of brought that out about it so he
actually did finally get convicted of
the [ __ ] when he was like [ __ ] 69
years old in 2014 he finally got
convicted of all these [ __ ] murders
at 69 at 69 years old and sadly he died
only four years later in 2019 it's
almost kind of like getting away with it
well he did get away yeah for a really
long time cuz like I said if he hadn't
done this murder he did the World's End
murder that was in Borough but they
didn't find it like because that crime
was so high-profile and Angus Sinclair
was a suspect at the time and like I
said you can't forget - this was two
dudes that did this and guessing Clair
did some [ __ ] by himself obviously he
did a bunch of [ __ ] by himself like he
raped little girls and murdered little
girls
he murdered several other women but he
also had an accomplice his [ __ ]
brother-in-law
Goren Hamilton who only got away with it
because he [ __ ] croaked in 1996 and
they didn't get to him in time so I'm
just saying so Angus Sinclair turned out
being one of the worst serial killers in
Scotland and they didn't [ __ ] catch
him until later on and then he was only
spent like four years in prison and then
he [ __ ] dropped dead
and from everything that I have read
about everyone that interviewed and
everything interviewed him is that he
was like the worst person ever
they said that he just would sit there
and I saw this one interview with him
always so it was like really creepy so
they're like interviewing him about some
[ __ ] he will just sit there and look at
you he won't like talk he won't do it he
just said
CERN looks yeah he doesn't give a single
[ __ ] yeah and most of the investigators
said that this is a total sociopath he
has no feelings
he has no empathy he has no remorse um
you just look at his face it's like he
won't
he doesn't talk he doesn't do anything
he just like looks at you and he doesn't
care like 20 yeah it's like nothing you
say to him makes any difference and it's
like he doesn't care and like I said if
you had listened to the psychologist
back in the 60s yeah who said that
please keep this [ __ ] in custody
because he's not right and he's messed
up maybe we wouldn't be here but you
know like I said hindsight is 20/20
you can't predict like what people are
gonna do some people like work it out
and work out okay but I in this
situation the psychologists were
completely correct because this dude is
I mean and everyone I've seen that like
talk to him it's of the city he's just a
monster he's a monster like he really
does not care about anything or anyone
that dude needed his ass beaten I kind
of wish it's like when I saw the
documentary and like I said and they
were talking to his brother who was a
little bit older than him and his
brother had said initiative I mean
essentially that I wish I'd killed it he
was and you could see that he was kind
of like upset about it I'm like yeah I
think everywhere I wish you had done it
I mean like I don't blame him for not
doing it cuz he was just a kid at the
time you got in trouble if you did that
in that's what I mean in a trauma
cheating it wouldn't have worked out
right but in hindsight he's like man I
wish I had killed him and that's [ __ ]
up that's [ __ ] up to think that about
your brother so that it I yeah that's it
okay all right
you don't yeah
[Laughter]
all right that dudes a [ __ ] up dude
man what he's dead now he's dead he just
he died recently yeah well not that
recently about in 2000 I do but yeah so
hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
rambling drunken discussion yes about
various UK crimes that you guys have
suggested it was still a good show do
you think yeah it was still good I hope
so we'll see one way I enjoyed it I
enjoy yeah and he just gets back to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] no I'm sure everybody says
it look oh there's there's mouth she's
like and spin it it's live she streamed
look at it yeah you could yep guys
couldn't subscribe this court to obscura
Undead yeah she arrived yes she's cool
chick
oh yeah all right so okay so this is
episode 192 like share subscribe please
like share subscribe it really does help
out a lot like I said if we're gonna
launch the YouTube membership thing
we'll see ya take to like [ __ ] come
into fruition but we'll see if you'd
like to financially support the show at
the moment you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
which is at the blog 13 o'clock podcast
at wordpress.com and there's a button in
the sidebar that goes to a PayPal
account and like I said hey Jason I'm
gonna get you a t-shirt I promise we're
gonna do the [ __ ] will do like we just
have we haven't done t-shirts for
anybody yeah we just got an open society
has to open back up I'm gonna order some
[ __ ] and like nothing is coming it's
like I don't think everything's taking
like a minute to get here the money's
not the problem is the supply once we
have it yeah every like the shirts think
it's like it's awkward to get right now
because everything is like taking one of
these clothes yeah but I I swear to god
we will get you some [ __ ] because we
have another like PayPal contributor
named Melanie who contributes like every
month or so like through PayPal and
she's
the t-shirt and it passed so we don't
forget about you guys it's just that
right now it's kind of like an awkward
time you know well we'll get to you we
promise so anyway hopefully you guys
have enjoyed this discussion on Episode
one A two and we will see you next time
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]